WE'LL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN THE
COMMITTEE TODAY AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AS WE WAIT ON MEMBERS --
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- CALMER DIVERS
BEEN APPOINTED TO FILL THE
VACANCY OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA FOR TODAY'S HEARING -- WE
HAVE FIFTEEN BILLS ON THE AGENDA.
ITEM SEVEN MEMBERS AB EIGHT
FORTY HAS BEEN TAKEN OFF THE
CALENDAR BY THE AUTHOR SO PLEASE
MAKE THAT NOTE -- WE HAVE FOUR
BILLS ON THE PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH WE WILL DIE OUT
TO ONLY GET A QUORUM THAT'S I
HAD A MATE AB EIGHT SIXTY BERMAN
ITEM NINE AB TEN EIGHTY TWO LOAN.
ITEM TWELVE AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
THREE GRAY AND ITEM THIRTEEN AB
FIFTEEN FORTY ONE GRAY.
AND AT THIS TIME WE WILL BEGIN
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAHLE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO COME UP IN.
PRESENT YOUR LATEST AND GREATEST
FINE PIECE OF LEGISLATION FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND STAFF US THE FIRST
TIME I'VE EVER BEEN IN FRONT OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND I HOPE I DO
WELL.
AS A AS YOU MAYBE WHERE A I HAVE
AB TWO FORTY SEVEN WHICH IS A A
BILL THAT TIME WE HAD THE ONE
POINT SIX MILLION ACRES BURNED
LAST YEAR IN CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY -- THIS COUPLE AS
FIRES WERE IN MY DISTRICT AND
THE MONEY THAT -- FEMA COMES IN
AND HELPS OUT WITH IT -- YES
THERE'S A LOCAL PART THAT --
DOESN'T GET COVERED AND IT'S A
FEW MILLION DOLLARS AND SO THIS
BILL IS SITE SPECIFIC -- TO MY
DISTRICT ACTUALLY WHERE WE WANT
TO BACK FILL THAT COST THE
COUNTY SO WE CAN CAN YOU KNOW
SERVICES SO I KNOW IT'S A
SUPPORT SUPPORT BILL I DON'T
WANT TO BE LABOR IT MUCH MORE
THAN THAT.
I DO WILL ANSWER QUESTIONS IF
YOU'D LIKE IT I THAT I ASKED --
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THE BILL.
THE SHERMAN MEMBERS PAUL YODER --
WE HAVE THE BOARD SU RISERS IN --
SHASTA AND SISKIYOU COUNTIES
SUPPORT SUPPORT SOUNDS GOOD TO
ME THANK YOU.
EVERY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
KAPITI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
MARIAN WARMER DAM ON THE HAVE A
RURAL COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
ROBERT SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
JEFF KNEW THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
FALCONS OFFICE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF READING AND SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S AFFECT WORKERS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FIREFIGHTERS
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT.
THE C. NO ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WE
HAVE ANYONE HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ALL BRING IT BACK TO
THE MEMBERS FOR ANY QUESTIONS
CONCERNS.
WELL DONE MISTER DALI SOON AS WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WILL -- GO
HEAD MOVE FORWARD WITH YOUR BILL
THANK YOU.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS.
SURE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO AB
SIXTEEN OH ONE AND WELCOME -- SO
MEMBER RAMOS [inaudible] TO
PRESENT.
HIS BILL ONE MORE
.
RAINY -- COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
GEO OUT THERE WE NEED ONE MORE
FOR A QUORUM SO.
FIND YOUR WAY TO OUR ROOM.
FORTY TWO OH TWO THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AB SIXTY NO.
ONE ESTABLISHES THE POSITION OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AT THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. TO ENSURE
THE VITAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES ARE DELIVERED TO THOSE
MOST IN NEED DURING TIMES OF
CRISIS.
IT ALSO REQUIRES A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR TO COLLABORATE.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO COORDINATE THE
DELIVERY OF TRAUMA RELATED
SUPPORT TO INDIVIDUALS AFFECTED
BY A NATURAL DISASTER OR STATE
OF EMERGENCY.
THE WILD FIRES THAT RAGED
THROUGH CALIFORNIA IN THE LATE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BECAUSE
HISTORIC LEVELS OF DAMAGE AND
DEVASTATION.
THIS QUICK AND SUDDEN FIRESTORM
LET THE GOVERNOR TO DECLARE A
STATE OF EMERGENCY IN SEVERAL
COUNTIES.
IN TOTAL WILD FIRES BURNED OVER
ONE POINT TWO MILLION ACRES OF
LAND.
DAMAGING OR DESTROYING OVER
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND HOMES. FOUR
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
BUSINESSES.
AND SAN BERNARDINO.
HAS COUNTY SUPERVISOR NOW IS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR THE FORTIETH
DISTRICT.
TERRORISM AND VIOLENT STRUCK IN
OUR AREA AND HAD AN EFFECT ON
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY.
A DISTRICT IN THE TRAGEDY OF THE
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN ATTACKS AND
STAMINA DINO.
WERE FOURTEEN PEOPLE WERE KILLED
AND TWENTY TWO OTHERS SERIOUSLY
INJURED.
HAVE A DEAD IT HAD A DEVASTATING
ATTACK AN IMMEDIATE IMPACT ON
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
WELL THESE TRAGEDIES HAVE
REFLECTED THE RESILIENCE OF OUR
COMMUNITY INTERRUPT YOU FOR ONE
SECOND AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM
BEFORE SOUNDS GOOD NUMBERS NOW
IS ON A ROLL.
SAVE THAT SPOT ALL RIGHT.
SEC TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
HERE BIGELOW.
THANK YOU ARE CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CONTACT [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER.
DALY YOUR GALLAGHER.
GARCIA GIPSON NEAR [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY HERE LOW.
MATHIS YOUR MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
READ THIS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT BREAK IN THE
ACTION IS RAMOS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU.
WELL THESE TRAGEDIES HAVE
REFLECTED THE RESILIENCE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THE STATE HAS NOT
BEEN PREPARED TO MANAGE THE
MEDIA MENTAL HEALTH IMPACTS OF
CRISIS IN EMERGENCIES.
AB SIXTY NO ONE WILL ENSURE THAT
THIS GAP AND EMERGENCY SERVICES
IS CLOSED AND THAT IN TIMES OF
CRISIS OUR COMMUNITIES GET THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES THEY
NEED.
WITH ME TODAY IS ADRIAN SHELTON
REPRESENTING THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL AS WELL AS VERONICA CALLIE
DECEMBER DINO COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTOR HERE TO SHARE
THEIR EXPERIENCES AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ADRIN SULTAN WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE WE ARE THE
PROUD SPONSORS OF ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN NO.
ONE AND THIS BILL IS REALLY
ABOUT STRENGTHENING THE MENTAL
HEALTH RESPONSE FOLLOWING
EMERGENCIES IN OUR STATE
ENSURING THAT THERE'S ACCESS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS.
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ACROSS THE STATE
ADMINISTER CRITICAL MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES.
AND DURING A DISASTER THEY ARE
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK THEY'RE
TAKING STOCK OUT OF CLINICS
THEIR TRIAGE SCENE ALL THE WHILE
CONDUCTING BUSINESS IN SERVING
THEIR CLIENTS THAT THEY WERE.
PRIOR TO THE EMERGENCY SO WE
REALLY FEEL THAT IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT PLANNING OCCUR
PRIOR TO AN EMERGENCY SO IT'S
NOT A CALL FOR HELP IN THE DARK
BUT IN HIS INSTEAD GUIDED.
AND A WELL THOUGHT THOUGHT OUT
RESPONSE WITH THE TEAM WHO IS
PREPARED TO ADDRESS THE FISCAL
REQUIREMENTS OF THE NEEDS OF THE
VICTIMS AND EFFECTIVE WAY.
THERE IS ALSO OVERWHELMING
EVIDENCE FROM NATIONAL DATA THAT
THE MAJORITY OF INJURIES OR
TRAUMA FOLLOWING DISASTERS IS
PSYCHOLOGICAL AS OPPOSED TO
PHYSICAL SO THIS BILL RECOGNIZES
THE ACUTE NEED IN OUR STATE. TO
PROVIDE A MORE STANDARDIZED
DISASTER MENTAL HEALTH
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE IT
BUILDS ON WHAT IS CURRENTLY IN
PLACE AND PROVIDES ANOTHER TOOL
FOR TO HELP CALIFORNIANS RECOVER
FROM DRAMATIC EMERGENCIES THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU THE SONOMA SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DOCTOR
VERONICA CAL AND BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DIRECTOR FOR SAN BERNADINO
COUNTY.
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE TASKED
WITH PROVIDING TREATMENT FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SERIOUS AND
PERSISTENT MENTAL ILLNESSES LIKE
SCHIZOPHRENIA. FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH WITH SERIOUS EMOTIONAL
DISTURBANCE AND FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE ADDICTIONS OUR TARGET
POPULATION IS THE MEDICARE
POPULATION.
PEOPLE LIVING IN POVERTY PEOPLE
WHO HAVE NO INSURANCE SO IN
EFFECT WE ARE THE SAFETY NET FOR
CALIFORNIA.
BUT ON DECEMBER SECOND TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE WERE ALSO
CHARGED WITH PROVIDING.
CRITICAL INCIDENT DEBRIEFING
CRISIS INTERVENTION TO THE
RESIDENTS OF SAN BERNADINO
COUNTY TORE COUNTY FAMILY INTO
OUR DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
IN PARTICULAR WHEN TO TERRACE
KILLED FOURTEEN PEOPLE AND
WOUNDED.
TWENTY TWO AND DURING THAT
COUNTY EVENT.
THE PUBLIC COUNTY DEPARTMENT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPLOYED THREE
HUNDRED CLINICAL BOOTS ON THE
GROUND IN THE FIRST FORTY EIGHT
HOURS WE PROVIDE AT ELEVEN
THOUSAND CRISIS AND COUNTERS.
AND THAT WAS BEFORE A TOTAL OF
APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN HUNDRED
CONTINUAL HOURS OF CRISIS
INTERVENTION ALL THE WHILE
KEEPING OUR DOORS OPEN SERVING
THE CLIENTS WE ARE CHARGED TO
SERVE.
WE WERE THEN MATT WITH ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT ACTIVE SHOOTER EVENT
IN SAN BERNARDINO CITY AT THE
NORTH PARK ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
ADJACENT CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
SAMBAR NINETEEN NOW.
IT WAS A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
INCIDENT IN WHICH A HUSBAND
ENTERED THE CLASSROOM OF HIS
WIFE IS.
A TEACHER OF A SECOND AND THIRD
GRADE SPECIAL EDUCATION GROUP HE
SHOT AND KILLED HER IN FRONT OF
THOSE STUDENTS.
WOUNDING TWO STUDENTS ONE WHO
ALSO DIED AND THEN SHOT HIMSELF
IN FRONT OF THOSE CHILDREN WE
PROVIDED THE CRISIS INTERVENTION
THERE.
WITHIN RESPONDED TO OUR OWN BLUE
CUT AND PILOT FIRES FOLLOWED BY
STATE WHAT FIRES IN CINEMA
COUNTY NAPA COUNTY BUTTE AND
MENDOCINO COUNTIES.
WE HAD THE RANCHO TO HAMMER
RESERVE SHOOTING THAT'S ABOUT A
HUNDRED MILES FROM HERE THAT
KILLED FIVE PEOPLE WERE EIGHTEEN
PEOPLE WERE SHOT.
THE YOUNG BILL VETERANS HOME
SHOOTING AND NAPA THAT KILLED.
FIVE THE LAS VEGAS SHOOTING AND
WHILE THAT'S NOT PARTICULAR TO
ANY PARTICULAR COUNTY SAN GONNA
DO YOU KNOW COUNTY.
HAD SIX COUNTY EMPLOYEES WHO
WERE SHOT IN THAT LAS VEGAS
SHOOTING AND ONE WHO WAS
MURDERED.
A RECENT BORDERLINE BAR GRILL IN
THOUSAND OAKS VENTURA COUNTY
WHERE THIRTEEN PEOPLE WERE
KILLED AND TWELVE WERE INJURED.
FOLLOWED HOURS LATER BY THE
VENTURA FIRES AND FIRES AND
THIRTY SIX COUNTIES MANY
COUNTIES EXPERIENCING MORE THAN
ONE FIRE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN AND WHILE OUR AMAZING
FIRST RESPONDERS DID THEIR JOBS.
HERE HOUSE ALL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ALSO DID HOURS.
BUT OUR COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
HAS BEEN LEFT TO ITS OWN DEVICES
WE DO WHAT WE CAN.
I HAVE PERSONALLY CONSULTED WITH
NUMEROUS COUNTIES DURING THEIR
CRISES BECAUSE NOBODY ELSE IS.
AND WE COUNTIES ARE CONSTITUENTS
DESERVE BETTER.
PLEASE SUPPORT THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES A
POSITION THAT MAKES SENSE AND
CAN DEPLOYED DURING EMERGENCIES
TO ASSIST COUNTY TO RESPOND. TO
THE PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACTS OF
EACH OF THESE UNFORTUNATELY
FREQUENTLY OCCURRING EVENTS
THANK YOU.
OKAY DECISIONAL Là TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
AMANDA LEVY THAT THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON COUNTY DELGADO ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THE MADDEN REVERSING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS
IN SUPPORT.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
MAURICE REGIS AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
I LANDED ON BEHALF OF NEXT AND
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
AFTERWARDS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
A SINGLE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
SPORT WE HAVE ANYONE HERE TODAY
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING THAT WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND MEMBERS THIS IS DUE
PASSED A HEALTH COMMITTEE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT FIVE FOR A AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DAILY DALY AYE
GALLAGHER.
AND WE'RE GARCIA GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW.
LOW AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE
AYE QUIRK KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE HI.
ROBERT RIVAS [inaudible]
BLANCA RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU COMMITTEE.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA MOVED ITEM ONE ON YOUR
AGENDA WE'RE GOING TO ASK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD TO PLEASE.
COME FORWARD AND PRESENT AB.
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR WELCOME PROCEED
THANKS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
ON OCTOBER IN OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE TUBS FIRE
STARTED IN CALISTOGA AND IN FOUR
HOURS.
THIS WEB TWELVE OUT OF TWELVE
MILES THROUGH CINEMA COUNTY AND
INTO THE CITY SANTA ROSA.
THE FIRE DESTROYED FIVE THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
STRUCTURES AND TOOK THE LIVES OF
TWENTY TWO PEOPLE.
NEARLY ALL OF THEM FROM
COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT.
THE TIME WE FELT AS THOUGH WE
JUST EXPERIENCE A ONCE IN A
GENERATION TRAGEDY.
SINCE THEN THE THOMAS WOLSEY CAR
IN CAMP FIRES HAVE PROVEN US
WRONG.
WE NOW UNDERSTAND THAT WE
EXPERIENCED IN THE TUB FIRE WHAT
WAS NOT A FREAK ACCIDENT OR THE
PERFECT STORM.
BUT THE PRODUCT OF A SYSTEMIC
CRISIS.
GENERATIONS OF CLEAR CUTTING
FOREST'S FOLLOWED BY FIRE
SUPPRESSION FOR BY COMMUNITY
SPRAWLING INTO WILD LANDS ALL
EXACERBATED BY A CHANGING
CLIMATE.
THIS IS PUT HUNDREDS OF TOWNS IN
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS AT RISK
OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES.
THIS CRISIS CALLS FOR SWIFT BOLD
ACTION AND A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT.
AND IT HAS TO START WITH THE
HOMES THEMSELVES.
AB THIRTY EIGHT PROPOSES A THREE
PRONGED APPROACH FIRST WE ARE
PROPOSING A LOT I KNOW OR LOW
INTEREST REVOLVING LOAN FUND. TO
HELP PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
HOMEOWNERS TO RETROFIT THEIR
PREVIOUSLY CONSTRUCTED HOMES IN
VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY
ZONES.
WE HAVE LIFTED MANY OF THE
PROVISIONS FROM OTHER SUCCESSFUL
LOAN FOR RETROFIT PROGRAMS
INCLUDING THE SEISMIC SAFETY
FINANCING PROGRAM.
AND WE'RE WORKING WITH THE STATE
TREASURER AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ON HOW BEST TO ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM.
SECOND WE ARE WORKING WITH FIRE
SCIENTISTS AND BUILDING ON MS
FRIEDMAN'S AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN
FROM LAST YEAR THAT TASK THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL WITH
IDENTIFYING LOW COST RETROFITS.
RASKIN HOMEOWNERS TO CERTIFY
THAT THESE RETROFITS OF TAKEN
PLACE BEFORE AT THE TOP OF THE
HOME IS SOLD.
FINALLY WE'RE PROPOSING A STATE
WILD FIRE PREPAREDNESS BOARD AND
A NETWORK OF REGIONAL WILDFIRE
PREVENTION DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE
PLANNING.
EDUCATIONAL AND SOME AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CAPACITY TO
FIRE PRONE COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE.
THEIR ENTRY ENTITIES ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA DOING GREAT WORK OF
PREPARING COMMITTEES FOR FIRE.
BUT IS EXCEPTIONALLY
INCONSISTENT FROM COMMUNITY TO
COMMUNITY.
AND IS OFTEN THE CASE THE
COMMUNITIES WITH THE FEWER THE
FEWEST RESOURCES TO SPARE ARE
GENERALLY LESS PREPARED.
MEMBERS THIS IS NOT A SILVER
BULLET IS TAKEN AS GENERATIONS
TO GET INTO THIS SITUATION IT
WILL TAKE US YEARS TO GET OUT OF
IT.
BUT I BELIEVE AB THIRTY EIGHT
MOVES US IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
HERE IN SAID TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS FORMER STATE FIRE
MARSHAL CAKE DARGAN.
AND LIVED LIVES FORSBERG WITH
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY.
THANK YOU I'LL GO FIRST I AM
CAIT DARGAN SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THIS BILL I WANT TO
COMPLIMENT ASSEMBLYMAN WOODS FOR
HIS EFFORT TO DO A DIFFICULT
TASK.
UP I'LL TELL A SHORT STORY ABOUT
HOW WE GOT TO THIS PARTICULAR
JUNCTURE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING CODES IN TWO THOUSAND
AND ABOUT TWO THOUSAND AND ONE
WE BEGIN A RESEARCH PROJECT AT
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE.
TO DETERMINE HOW BUILDING
SPECIFICALLY BURNT RELATIVE TO
WILD FIRE THAT RESULTED IN FIVE
TESTING STANDARDS WHICH WE THEN
CONVERTED INTO THE FIRST EVER
CHAPTER SEVEN A CALIFORNIA
BUILDING -- CODE.
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
BUILDING STANDARDS AT THAT TIME
THOSE PROVISIONS WERE TARGETED
FOR AT NEW CONSTRUCTION.
SINCE THAT TIME WE HAVE ALL
BECOME PAINFULLY AWARE THAT IT
IS THE EXISTING HOUSING STOCK
THAT IS AT DIRE RISK A DISASTER
FROM WILDFIRES. TO CORRECT THAT
PROBLEM THERE IS REALLY ONLY ONE
WAY FORWARD AND THAT IS TO
ADDRESS PHYSICAL CHANGE WITHIN
THE ZONE THAT WE CALL THE
STRUCTURAL IGNITION ZONE AND
THAT PHYSICAL CHANGES CHANGING
THE BUILDING ELEMENTS THAT ARE
MOST SUSCEPTIBLE TO AMBER
INTRUSION FROM WILD FIRE.
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT IS
IMPORTANT FOR COMMUNITY
PROTECTION BUT TO GET TO
BUILDING PROTECTION TO PROTECT
INDIVIDUAL HOMES FROM THE THREAT
OF EMBERS INDIRECT FLAME WE HAVE
TO CHANGE THE COMPONENTS OF THE
EXCUSE ME OF THAT BUILDING.
SO THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE NEED
FOR RETROFITS ON THE OVER TWO
MILLION HOMES THAT DO EXIST AS
EXISTING HOUSING.
STOCK OUT THERE IN THE STATE.
AND YES IT WILL TAKE AWHILE IT
IS A DIFFICULT LEFT BUT THERE IS
ONLY ONE WAY TO GET THERE AND
THAT IS TO CREATE BOTH A
DEFENSIBLE SPACE OWN AROUND THE
STRUCTURE.
AND THE IMPORTANT BUILDING
ELEMENTS SUCH AS WINDOWS VANCE
ROOFING MATERIALS COVERED
GUTTERS IT CETERA THAT PREVENTS
THE INTRUSION OF EMBERS -- FOR
THAT BUILDING RISK WITHOUT THOSE
ELEMENTS DEFENSIBLE SPACE ALONE
WILL NOT PROTECT THE STRUCTURE
NOR WILL JUST VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT THIS IS A CRITICAL
STEP.
IN THE RESILIENCY DEVELOPMENT
FOR CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LIZ FORCED
BURKE AND I'M THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF POLICY FOR THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY WE ARE HERE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTY EIGHT LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA SAW THE WORST FIGHT
WILDFIRES IN HISTORY SET A NEW
RECORD FOR THE LARGEST MOST
DESTRUCTIVE AND DEADLY US.
IN THE FACE OF MAKE THE FIRES WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO INVEST
IN AND CREATE FIRE RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES.
WELL WE CAN'T STOP THIS PROGRAM
PROBLEM OVERNIGHT THERE ARE TWO
THINGS WE NEED TO INVEST IN
IMMEDIATELY TO BETTER PROTECT
PEOPLE IN NATURE IN THE FACE OF
WILDFIRE.
FORCED RESTORATION AND FIRE
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES.
LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA MADE A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR COMMITMENT TO
FOREST HEALTH AND FEELS
REDUCTION OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS.
WHEN YOU COMPARE BELOW
INVESTMENT IN COMMUNITY
PROTECTION PROVIDED BY A. B.
THIRTY EIGHT TO ADAPT OUR
COMMUNITIES TO DEAL WITH THE
ESCALATING THREAT OF FIRES?
AND FOR COMMITTEES ARE
ESTABLISHED IN HIGH RISK FIRE
AREAS WE MUST MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROVIDE RESOURCES AN EXPERT WHO
CAN HELP WITH FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES.
THE REGIONAL WILDFIRE PREVENTION
DISTRICTS CREATED IN AB THIRTY
EIGHT WILL ENSURE COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE WILL HAVE FIBER
PREVENTION PLANS.
AND ACCESS TO TECHNICAL OCT
PARTIES IN ASSISTANCE TO IMPROVE
FIRE SAFETY.
LET'S STOP MAKING HISTORY AND
START FIXING THE PROBLEMS
THROUGH BOLD MEASURES LIKE AB.
THIRTY EIGHT WE THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT.
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL -- TESTIMONY
SUPPORT.
CAN STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF ALL STATE INSURANCE
AND SUPPORT.
SINGLE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY DO
WE HAVE ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION HERE TODAY.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE -- FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS IN
THE MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR MISTER
GIPSON SECOND FOR MISTER
GALLAGHER.
CORRECTION SECOND FOR MR SALAS.
SIR WHAT I'VE -- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS YOU AGREED. TO
A SERIES OF AMENDMENTS YES YES I
HAVE THAT PERTAINS TO THE
COMMENTS RAISED BY THE COMMITTEE
IN THE IN THE ANALYSIS AND
THAT'S FIRST REMOVE THE RETROFIT
REQUIREMENTS SECOND TO REMOVE
THE PROVISIONS -- DESIGNATE THE
EIGHTEEN NEW REGIONAL WILDFIRE
PREVENTION DISTRICTS OF STATE
AGENCIES INSTEAD THEY WILL BE
ADVISORY BODIES TO THE NEW STATE
BOARD WITHOUT -- ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY.
AND THEN -- WILL ADD TO DIRECTOR
CALLOW YES AND ONE APPOINTEE --
FROM BOTH THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY TO THE NEW STATE BOARD
IS MY UNDERSTANDING.
I DO HAVE.
A COUPLE QUESTIONS -- ONE WE
REFERENCE -- IN THE ANALYSIS.
THE REQUIRING OF SELLERS IN THE
FUTURE TO UNDERTAKE LOW COST
RETROFITS AND I'M CURIOUS WHAT
WORK VISION IS LOW COST RETROFIT
SINCE THAT'S KIND OF AN
AMBIGUOUS.
TERM.
I APOLOGIZE FIRST BY APOLOGIZE
WE WE HAVE NOT AGREED TO
REMOVING THE EIGHTEEN THE THE
RETROFITS EXCUSE ME -- NOW.
THE LONG WE'RE GOOD TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON ON WE HAVE NOT AGREED
TO REMOVE THE RETROFIT
REQUIREMENTS.
OKAY WE SEEM TO HAVE A LITTLE
CONFUSION THERE -- WHAT WE HONOR
THE HEART OF THE BILL?
WITHOUT THE RED RIVER
REQUIREMENT THERE'S NO NEED FOR
REVOLVING LOAN FUND.
WALL -- TABLE THAT FOR THE
MOMENT AND YOU AND I'LL WORK ON
THAT GOING FORWARD -- AS A
PERTAINS TO THE AND I WAS
BELIEVE ME -- RE DIRECT YOU BACK
TO MY QUESTION ON LOW ON LOW
COST RETROFITS WHAT WHAT ARE WE
ARE.
WE LOW COST AND SOME COMMUNITIES
IN SOME SEVERE TO SOME BUILDINGS
IS.
DIFFERENT.
IN OTHERS SURE.
EXAMPLES AND I COSTS ARE ARE FOR
STATE FARMERS OR TO WIN AS WELL
THINGS LIKE VENTS SCREENS --
SOFFITS GETTER GUARDS -- AND
CREATING NON COMBUSTIBLE ZONES
ARE ADJACENT TO THE HOUSE THOSE
ARE.
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE LOW COST NOT
TALKING ABOUT REPLACEMENT OF
ROOFS. FOR CITING AND WE'RE TALK
ABOUT LOW WITH ESSENTIALLY LOW
COST.
ANY OTHER.
COMMENT I'LL MAKE SOME RIVER IN
THE THIS GOES BACK A LITTLE BIT
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE WE HAD OVER
NINE A ONE LAST RECESSION -- I
RAISE THE ISSUE.
SEVERAL TIMES AND IN THIS
COMMITTEE.
ON HOW WE'RE SHARING THE COST
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN THIS
CASE FOR TIME A BILLION DOLLARS
OF GENERAL FUND MONEY WHICH
OBVIOUSLY THAT -- BURDEN WILL BE
SHARED EQUALLY ACROSS CALIFORNIA
BY ALL -- TAXPAYERS -- SPECIFIC
BACK TO THAT ONE DISCUSSION WAS
MY CONCERN THAT YOU'RE DOWN AND
FOR EXAMPLE MIKE TO BEING SUCH A
VALUE WE HAVE -- A CLIMATE THAT
REQUIRES LARGER HE'D YOUR
HEATING COOLING BILLS AND
THROUGHOUT YOUR GREAT STRUCTURE
THAT COST IS SHARED BY EVERYBODY
IS.
BORN ON BY MY CONSTITUENTS AND
COMMERCIAL OR DEAL WITH SOME OF
THESE NATURAL DISASTERS AND FIRE
ISSUES -- WILL START TO SPREAD
THOSE COST OUT ACROSS THE WHOLE
STATE IT GIVES ME A LITTLE BIT
OF CONCERN IN HOW WE HANDLE THAT
NOT A CONCERN THAT -- ISN'T
GOING.
TO GET MY SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
TODAY BUT I JUST WANT TO RAISE
IT WITH YOU AGAIN AS WE HAVE
THESE ONGOING DISCUSSIONS. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET.
INTO SOME EQUITY -- THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA I'M DEALING WITH --
IT SPECIFIC.
YOU KNOW CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUES
FRANKLY TO OUR RESPECTIVE
REGIONS.
I APPRECIATE THAT I MEAN IN MY
DISTRICT -- WE HAVE VERY CLEAN
AIR AND YET WE'RE SUBJECT.
TO REQUIREMENTS BY THE A. R. B.
THAT ARE DIFFICULT TO ATTAIN
BECAUSE I HAVE POOR COMMUNITIES
AS WELL SO SOMETIMES IN I I
WOULD VENTURE TO SAY THAT YOU
KNOW WE DO THINGS FOR THE
GREATER GOOD OF THE STATE.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS EQUITABLE AND I
TRUST ME I TAKE A LOT OF VOTES
ON A LOT OF THINGS THAT ARE
EQUITABLE FOR MY COMMUNITIES --
BUT I BELIEVE IT'S AN IN THE
GREATER GOOD FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING WE SHARE IN COMMON
PORTIONS OF OUR DISTRICT -- AND
I KNOW YOU APPRECIATE --
ABSOLUTELY -- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS OR ISSUES
REMEMBERS MR BIGELOW.
AND I I APPRECIATE DR WITH WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE AND
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
WHICH IS A SAFER HOME AND AS A
FIREMAN I CAN REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT -- GOING INTO IT SOMETIMES
THE PRODUCTS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE ARTIST SAFE IS.
WE'D LIKE THEM TO BE FOR THE
FIREMAN AS ARE FIGHTING A FIRE --
BECAUSE IT DID CREATE SOME
HEALTH OTHER ISSUES FOR THEM AND
FINDING IT -- GIVEN THAT SAID.
THERE HAS BEEN OVER A NUMBER OF
YEARS -- A POWER GIVEN TO THE
LOCAL CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
ACTUALLY ENFORCE AND TAKE ACTION
UPON PUTTING THESE OF BUILDING
CODES IN PLACE.
AND THEY HAVE AN ACTED UPON IT.
SECOND FOLD IS THEIR CODE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES HAVEN'T
DONE THEIR BEST AT ENFORCING THE
THE CLEARANCES AND AND THIS --
THE THAT THINGS THAT ARE
NECESSARY. TO BE COMPLIANT TO BE
FIRE WHY IT'S SO WE HAVE A HOST
OF THINGS THAT THE LOCALS
HAVEN'T DONE.
ON THAT COULD HAVE BEEN DONE AND
SHOULD BE DONE CURRENTLY.
YOUR BILL MAKES A VERY.
CHALLENGING THOUGH RIGHT NOW AS
WE MOVE FORWARD FOR PEOPLE LET'S
SAY A DOCTOR WAS HAS ALWAYS AND
RECEIVED AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
IN ANOTHER LOCATION.
MAYBE IN THE STATE OR OUT OF THE
STATE AND YOU HAVE TO SELL YOUR
HOUSE DID YOU HAVE TO MOVE
WITHIN.
A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
WITH THIS REQUIREMENT IN PLACE
AND YOUR HAVE THE RESOURCES.
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO SELL YOUR
HOUSE YOU'RE CAUGHT IN A
CONUNDRUM.
WHAT TO DO?
HI HOW IS THIS GOING TO WORK IS
NOW YOU GOTTA HAVE A CERTIFICATE
BEFORE YOU SELL IT AND YOU CAN'T
SELL IT.
UNTIL YOU'VE GOT ALL THE WORK
DONE AND YOU DIDN'T HAVE THE
MONEY OR THIS FUND DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH RESOURCES TO MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR YOU TO HAVE THE THE
THE PROJECT DONE.
AT APPRECIATE WORK APPRECIATE
WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM MY MY
HOPE IS THAT THIS IS THE FUND
WILL BE SOLVENT AND AND ARE.
ADEQUATE -- AT THE TIME OF SALE
THE HOUSE THERE'S POTENTIALLY
MORE MONEY ON THE TABLE THAN
THERE EVER WILL BE.
SO -- WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ARE REALLY PRETTY LOW COST ITEMS
LIKE I SAY WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT ROOFS WHEN I TALK ABOUT
CITING?
AND KEEPING YOU KNOW KEEPING
THINGS AWAY FROM YOUR HOUSE AT A
COMBUSTIBLE -- CERTAINLY -- IT'S
NOT AN EXPENSIVE THING TO DO
NECESSARILY -- MAYBE THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL WOULD LIKE TO OUR
FORMER STATE FIRE MARSHAL LIKE
TO WIN THE AYE I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
BUT IT I STAFF.
HOW MANY EXCEPTIONS DO WE DO WE
PUT IN PLACE HERE OVER TIME --
AND TO END UP CREATING A BIGGER
PROBLEM THAN THAN WHAT YOU
ALREADY YOU'VE ALREADY SPOKEN
ABOUT YOUR ABSOLUTE RIGHT CITIES
DON'T ENFORCE WHAT THEY SHOULD
BE DOING AND THEY SHOULD BE
DOING THAT -- COUNTIES OR NOT
AND FORCING WITH THEY SHOULD BE
DOING AND THEY SHOULD BE DOING
THAT -- OUR STATE AGENCIES ARE
NOT ALWAYS DOING THAT AS WELL --
WE SHOULD AND AND WE SHOULD BE
DOING THAT AND I WOULD HOPE THAT
PEOPLE WOULD WAKE UP AND REALIZE
THAT WE HAVE TO ENFORCE THOSE
RULES ARE ON THE BOOK AND PEOPLE
NEED TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT.
BUY THEIR OWN HOMES NOT TRYING
TO I KNOW THERE'S GOING TO
CREATE SOME HEARTBURN FOR PEOPLE
ON THIS I HAVE A LOT OF POOR
PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITIES WHICH
IS WHY WE SET UP THIS FINE --
AND LIKE I SAID WHEN YOU GO TO
SELL A HOUSE YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
MORE MONEY ON THE TABLE THAN YOU
PROBABLY EVER WILL -- AND WE YOU
KNOW WE WE WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT'S POTENTIAL CHALLENGE.
WELL I I I APPRECIATE THAT I
ANOTHER QUESTION IS WITH RESPECT
TO LOW COST IS NOT WELL DEFINED
INSIDE THE BILL.
HOW DO WE REALLY REMEDY THAT
BECAUSE I CAN TELL YOU I'M IN
THE PROCESS OF REMODELING AN
EXTERIOR OF THE HOUSE?
TRYING TO DO THE HARDENING.
AND IT'S NOT LOW COST IT COSTS A
LOT BUT MARTY PLAYING ON IT IT
COSTS A LOT TO PUT THE MUCH MORE
SECURED SO YOU DON'T GET THE
EMBERS INSIDE.
THESE ARE A LOT OF WHAT'S THAT
PEOPLE HAVE TO GO THROUGH AND
ENGINEERS HAVE TO PLAN OUT.
SYSTEMATICALLY.
AND NOT ALL OF IT IN FACT MOST
OF IT IS NOT LOW COST.
SO HOW DO WE GET THROUGH THAT
LANGUAGE OF THE LOW COST.
WELL AT THE STATE ARE OF THAT
OUR FORMER STATE FIRE MARSHAL
WEIGH IN ON THAT I KNOW I
APPRECIATE THAT.
YOUR HELP.
I'LL START WITH YOUR FIRST
QUESTION JUST -- I HAVE THE
LUXURY OF BEING WELL INFORMED ON
THE ISSUE.
AND RETIRED.
SO I CAN SPEAK AS FRANKLY AS I
CHOOSE TO SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE --
I GUESS I WANT TO GO BACK TO MY
FOR THE FIRST FEW SENTENCES IN
MY TESTIMONY.
THERE IS ONLY ONE WAY FORWARD ON
DEALING WITH THE RISK THAT
EXISTING STRUCTURES FACE
RELATIVE TO WILD FIRE AND THAT
IS A CONCERTED EFFORT. TO ENABLE
RETROFITS AND PROVIDE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE THAT IS BOTH THAT IS A
HEAVY LIFT IT WILL TAKE US YEARS
IF NOT.
I MEAN IT WILL TAKE US DECADES
TO GET THROUGH THAT PROBLEM BUT
WE MUST START SOMEWHERE THIS
BILL IS A WORTHY BEGINNING
EFFORT TO DEAL WITH THE RETROFIT
QUESTION AND ENFORCEMENT IS AN
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY COMPONENT.
AND ALL COMMUNITIES WHETHER THEY
BE LOCAL OR STATE OR FEDERAL
SHOULD BE ENFORCING.
THE RULES THAT WE HAVE ON THE
BOOKS WE HAVE HAD P. R. C. FORTY
TWO NINETY ONE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
REQUIREMENTS ON THE BOOKS FOR
FIFTY YEARS YOU HAVE HEARD THIS
BEFORE IN MY TESTIMONY TO OTHER
COMMITTEES.
THOSE PROVISIONS NEED TO BE
FULLY ENFORCED AROUND THE STATE.
RETROFITS MUST BEGIN.
THERE IS NO OTHER WAY TO PROTECT
OUR HOMES WITHOUT TACKLING THIS
ISSUE.
RELATIVE TO LOW COST ALL GOOD
PUBLIC PROGRAMS BEGIN WITH A
PHASED APPROACH AND SOME
CAPACITY BUILDING TO BEGIN THE
PROCESS AND I THINK THIS BILL.
CUES THAT UP WE ARE GOING TO
LEARN ALONG THE WAY I THINK LOW
COST UNDER TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
IS A BENCHMARK.
UNDERNEATH THAT FOR WHAT WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE WITHIN THE LOAN I'M
THROWING THAT OUT AS AN IDEA.
BUT THERE ARE A FEW COMPONENTS
TAKING DOWN THE LIST IN TERMS OF
WHAT.
IS MOST EFFECTIVE.
AND THE COMBINATION OF A FIRE OR
IGNITION RESISTANT ROUGH WHICH
ASPHALT SHINGLE ROOFS OR BETTER
MEET AND DEFENSIBLE SPACE
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE A HOMES
ABILITY TO SURVIVE.
VANCE AND SOFT PROTECTION ARE
THE NEXT ON THAT LIST AND
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AFTER THAT
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I WOULD
RECOGNIZING CONCUR WITH YOU
THERE IS THIS A SERIES OF STEPS
HERE TO ACHIEVE.
A TRUE HARDEN -- ENVIRONMENT BUT
EACH OF THOSE STEPS COMES WITH A
COST.
AND AS WE ARE ALL STRUGGLING
DOCTOR WOULD MYSELF EVERY MEMBER
HERE IS STRUGGLING STRUGGLING
DESPERATELY WITH FINDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR PEOPLE.
WE'RE PUTTING ANOTHER NAIL IN
THE COFFIN OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN THE STATE.
WHICH IS MAKING IT MORE AND MORE
DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO ENJOY
THE LUXURIES OF THE STATE NOW
GIVEN THAT SAID IT ALSO IS THE
OTHER CONUNDRUM.
WHICH IS BECAUSE WE LIVE IN A A
NEW SCENARIO OF LIFE OR WILDFIRE
IS THE THREAT.
WE'RE DRIVING UP THE COST THERE
AS WELL SO.
IT'S A HARD HARD ISSUE TO DEAL
WITH BUT RIGHT NOW WITHOUT THOSE
AMENDMENTS DOCTOR WHAT I I FIND
MYSELF.
A LITTLE CHALLENGE SO HOPEFULLY
THROUGH THE SERIES OF QUESTIONS
OF OTHER MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
ASK I MIGHT FIND IT A DIFFERENT
MINDSET BUT ALL ALL.
A CLOSE UP WITH MY QUESTIONING
AND SINCE THE CHAIR I SEE NOW
THE CHAIR HAS.
DISAPPEARED AND I AM NOW THE
ACTING -- LET ME.
WHO WAS FIRST BECAUSE I WASN'T
PAYING ATTENTION THAT?
OKAY MISTER GALLAGHER YOU HAVE A
QUESTION AND THEN MR DAILY.
AND THEN.
DODD -- SO I MEAN OBVIOUSLY THE
THE ISSUE THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
TACKLE HERE AS IT IS AN
IMPORTANT ONE AND AND PROBABLY
NO.
ONE THE TWO OF US BUT THE TWO OF
US PROBABLY KNOW THAT MORE THEM
US RIGHT OBVIOUSLY WITH
EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE GONE
THROUGH.
WHO LAST COUPLE YEARS AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I'VE HEARD? SIX
CERTAINLY IN THE AFTERMATH OF
THE CAMPFIRE WAS.
DEFENSIBLE SPACE THAT WAS
DEFINITELY AN ISSUE.
AND AND AND BEING ABLE TO
ENFORCE THAT BECAUSE MAYBE SOME
PEOPLE DECIDED I'M JUST NOT
GOING TO DO IT.
AND PROPERTY OWNERS NOT REALLY
HAVING THE ABILITY OR
NEIGHBORING PROPERTY OWNERS NOT
REALLY HAVING THE ABILITY OR
HARD NOT HAVING THE TEETH TO BE
ABLE TO ENFORCE THAT DEFENSIBLE
SPACE.
DEFINITELY WANT THEY ARE HEARD.
AND THEN THE OTHER THING THAT I
HEARD WAS AS WAS TALK ABOUT THE
THE MANY OF THE HOMES BURNED.
UP THERE FROM THE INSIDE OUT
BECAUSE EMBERS HAD ACTUALLY
GOTTEN IN UNDER THE EAVES.
INTO THE INTO THE HOMES AND IN
THAT AND THE FIRE ACTUALLY BURN
FROM THE INSIDE OUT SO.
I THINK BOTH OF THOSE THINGS ARE
IMPORTANT -- AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO GET AT
HERE -- THE THE ONE THING THAT I
THINK I'M I I MAY BE TROUBLED
WITH HIS.
IS OKAY WE KNOW WE NEED TO TRY
AND HELP RETROFIT THOSE.
THOSE BUILDINGS BUT IT MIGHT
TAKE TIME LIKE YOU SAID YOU KNOW
I THINK THE FIRE MARSHAL SAID
THIS COULD TAKE A DECADE OR MORE.
GET IT SEEMS LIKE IN THE BILL WE
HAVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AS AS
THE DEADLINE.
YOU KNOW CONSIDERING THAT COULD
BE I MEAN IF YOU CONSIDER MAYBE
MOVING THAT. TO MAKE THIS MORE
OF A PHASED IN APPROACH BECAUSE
IT IS GOING TO TAKE TIME AND
THERE IS GOING TO BE OF EVEN
WITH SOME MONEY AVAILABLE THERE
THERE'S GOING TO BE
AFFORDABILITY ISSUES MAYBE
THAT'S THE FIRST.
QUESTION I THINK I THINK WERE
I'M HAPPY TO CONSIDER HAPPY
CONSIDER THAT I GUESS I MEAN.
HOW MANY MORE YEARS OF
CATASTROPHIC FIRES WE HAVE HOW
MANY MORE LIVES HAVE TO BE LOST
HOW FAR DO WE PUSH THIS OUT?
YOU KNOW I MEAN I WOULD HOPE
THAT HOMEOWNERS WOULD.
BEGIN TO REALIZE I NEED TO DO
SOMETHING TO PROTECT MY HOME.
THESE ARE LOW COST SOME OF THESE
ARE PRACTICALLY NO COST JUST
ROLL ROLL UP YOUR SLEEVES OR
HAVE SOMEONE HELP YOU A LITTLE
BIT -- AT WHAT POINT DO WE TAKE
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR SOME
OF THESE ISSUES AND HELP PREVENT
AS MUCH AS WE CAN -- WE SETTING
UP A REVOLVING LOAN FUND -- ENDS
WITH LOW AND NO INTEREST LOANS --
CAN REALLY HELP SOME OF THE
LOWEST IN THE WITH THE POOREST
FOLKS IN OUR STATE -- AND THESE
OTHER OTHER RETROFITS ARE OR
TRIGGERED AT THE SALE OF THE
SALE OF A HOME -- I RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE'S THERE IS SOME
POTENTIAL HARPER ON THIS BUT I
WILL TELL YOU HAVING YOUR HOUSE
BURNED DOWN IS PROBABLY THE
WORST HEARTBURN OF ALL AND
THAT'S WERE TRYING TO PREVENT
HERE.
RIGHT SO.
BUT A COUPLE THINGS ONE IS OKAY
WHERE DOES THAT MONEY COME FROM
RIGHT BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS OF THE
GENERAL FUND THAT'S ALWAYS A
REALLY BIG ASK YOU KNOW AND I'M
SURE THAT AT SOME POINT THEY'RE
GOING TO SAY WELL.
DO YOU HAVE A FUN DO YOU HAVE
SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN PULL FROM.
I GUESS I'LL BE ONE PART AND
THEN YOU SAID HEY WHEN YOU SELL
YOUR HOUSE YOU HAVE MORE MONEY.
THAN YOU EVER GOING TO HAVE WILL
ONLY WHEN THE HOUSE IS SOLD IN
MONEY GETS TRANSFERRED TO YOU
OUT OF ESCROW
BETTER THIS BILL YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO GET THAT MONEY.
UNTIL YOU'VE SHOWN A
CERTIFICATION THAT YOU'VE DONE
SOMETHING SO YOU DON'T HAVE
MONEY. TO USE THAT SALE.
THAT MONEY IS NOT GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE TO YOU UNTIL YOU
ACTUALLY.
DO YOU PUT IN THE IMPROVEMENT
RIGHT -- SO CAN YOU MAYBE GO TO
THAT POINT AND I JUST HAVE ONE
LAST QUESTION SOME OF IT IF
YOU'RE LOW IN A IF IF IT'S IF
YOU'RE VERY LOW INCOME YOU'RE
GOING TO QUALIFY FOR THIS AND
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET THAT.
GET THAT RESOURCE THERE -- FROM
THIS FUND YEAH RIGHT BUT THEN
WHERE DO WE GET THE MONEY TO
FUND THE FUND.
RATE.
DO WE HAVE THAT AS A PROPOSAL
YET I THINK WE HAVE A PRETTY BIG
RAINY DAY FUND RIGHT NOW -- IT.
MAYBE MAYBE UP SOMETHING FROM
THERE MAYBE THERE'S SOME OTHER
RESOURCES I'M [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
BUT YOU AGREE WITH ME THAT WE'RE
NOT GONNA THE SALES PROCEEDS
BECAUSE THAT WAY I UNDERSTAND
AFTER RIGHT YEAH I I UNDERSTAND
BUT I DON'T BELIEVE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A HUGE HUGE AMOUNT.
OF RESOURCES TO TO DO THAT WILL
NOT DOES MY LAST PART BECAUSE
YOU WERE SAYING LOW THESE ARE
LOW COST IMPROVEMENTS.
BUT IT SOUND TO ME LIKE FROM THE
FIRE MARSHALL NUMBER ONE WHAT WE
NEED IS A NEW ROOF.
AND THAT WHICH IS NOT ONE OF
THEM NEEDED OUR ASKING.
FOR RIGHT.
BUT THAT'S WHAT I GET TO IS LIKE
A IT SEEMS LIKE THE MORE
FUNDAMENTAL THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO DO IS PEOPLE SHOULDN'T HAVE
WOOD SHAKE ROOFS MAYBE FOR
EXAMPLE THEY SHOULD HAVE.
BETTER ROOFS AND THAT WE NEED IN
THE YOU NEED THAT PROTECTION FOR
THE EVE SO THE EMBERS DON'T GET
IN.
IT'S NOT THOSE MIGHT BE MORE
COSTLY IMPROVEMENTS RIGHT.
IN THIS IS SAYING THAT AND IN
THOSE WOULDN'T BE REQUIRED YOUR
BILL RIGHT.
TEST TEST THE REQUIREMENT -- FOR
ROOFING STRUCTURES HAS BEEN IN
THE BUILDING CODE FOR I THINK
THIRTEEN OR FIFTEEN YEARS --
RELATIVE TO FIRE HAZARD TO VERY
SOON AND ROOFING SO IT'S NOT AT
ALL A NEW PROVISION.
SO IF PEOPLE COME IN FOR A
PERMIT NOW TO REPLACE THE ROSE.
FOR THE LAST I BELIEVE FIFTEEN
YEARS IT MIGHT BE SLIGHTLY OFF
WE HAVE REQURED THE PROPER
ROOFING ACCORDING TO FIRE HAZARD
TO BE PRESENT THAT'S NOT UNTIL
YOU COME IN TO DO A NEW ROOF
RIGHT I'M SOME CENTER THIS BILL
IS GOING TO REQUIRE RETROFITS.
RIGHT.
A I DON'T I DON'T SEE IT
REQUIRING SPECIFICALLY A ROUGH
I'M JUST SAYING THAT PEOPLE
FREQUENTLY DO REPLACE THE REST
BECAUSE IT IS A REPLACEABLE
PORTION OF THE BUILDING ELEMENT --
AS OPPOSED TO SOMETHING LIKE
EVENT -- THAT ARE NOT NORMALLY
REPLACE SO I GUESS MY QUESTION
IN THE WORLD IF WE ARE GOING TO
RETROFIT THESE STRUCTURES TO BE
MORE SAFE AND FIRE RESILIENT.
RIGHT AND IF THAT'S THE SPIRIT
OF THIS IS OF COURSE SORT OF
FORCE PEOPLE TO DO IT.
RIGHT.
RATHER THAN A RICH THAT WITHIN
SOME PERIOD OF TIME.
WAS NOT THE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
OR SAYING HEY BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE YOU HAVE TO DO THIS RIGHT.
THE THE GOAL -- AND IF ROOF
ISN'T PART OF THAT.
HAVE WE REALLY ACCOMPLISHED THE
OBJECT BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE
THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE THING YOU
NEED TO DO TO BE MORE FIRE.
RIGHT.
THE THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THE FUNDS.
FOR THE PEOPLE WOULD TAKE THAT.
BUT THEN THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT ARE THEY THEN
REQUEST LET'S SAY.
LET'S SAY YOUR PERSON WHO
DOESN'T QUALIFY FOR THE FUND.
RIGHT.
ARE YOU STILL BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE.
THE NEW ROOF IN THESE OTHER
REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT.
THE NEW FOR YEAH THE NEW ROOF IS
NOT A REQUIREMENT BUT IT'S
ELIGIBLE FOR THE LOAN OKAY BUT
THE LOW COST.
RETROFITS WOULD BE REQUIRED IS
THAT RIGHT YES AND I THINK I'LL
GO BACK TO WHAT THE BUT THE
CHAIR WAS TALKING ABOUT WHAT NOT
THAT CHAIR BUT THE OTHER CHAIR.
OF I'M SORRY.
YOU WERE OVER THERE A MINUTE AGO.
CLEARLY NOT MISTER GRAY SO -- SO
I BELIEVE THE POLICY THE POLICY
COME AT THE CHAIR WAS REFERRING
TO WAS THAT THE YOU WITH REGARD
TO RETROFITS WAS.
ASKING FOR CLARITY AROUND THOSE
RETROFIT RENT WOULD BE AND I
AGREE THAT WE WILL ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENT TO ASKING FOR CLARITY
AROUND THAT WORKING WITH THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL AND SO ON SO
WE DON'T.
HAVE THE CLARITY THAT YOU'RE
ASKING FOR THEIR BUT A ROOF IS
NOT.
REQUIRED IS NOT WHAT'S GONNA BE
REQUIRED BY TWENTY TO HARASS BUT
IT WILL BE REQUIRED OBVIOUSLY IF
YOU GO IN FOR A PERMIT FOR A NEW
ROOF.
EXCUSE ME THAT THAT WAS THE
POINT I WAS TRYING TO MAKE WHICH
IS IT'S NOT REQUIRED
SPECIFICALLY IN THIS BILL BUT
FOR THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS IT
HAS BEEN REQUIRED AS PART OF
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY SOUND
MEASURES.
IN THE BUILDING CODE.
IN THESE DISTRICTS WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENFORCING THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE TO WRITE THAT
WAS MY GOAL.
BUT IT'S MORE GOING TO BE MORE
ADVISORY NOW OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER WILSHIRE THANK
YOU -- MR DAILY.
THANK YOU I THINK THIS IS A VERY
NOBLE EFFORT AND WORTHWHILE AND
TIMELY AND MY I WANT TO SEE IT
SUCCEED [inaudible]
CURIOUS.
THE NEW BOARD THAT SET UP.
WILL THEY OVERSEE THE REVOLVING
LOAN FUND OR WHO WOULD
ADMINISTER WHO WOULD ACTUALLY DO
THE ADMINISTERING OF THE OF THE
LOANS THE STATE TREASURER
[inaudible]
STATE TREASURER.
GOOD THANK YOU.
I BELIEVE MR WAS NEXT -- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I WANT TO
ACTUALLY -- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE I KNOW
YOU MAY BE MORE THAN ANY OF US
HAVE SEEN -- WHAT DEVASTATION
LOOKS LIKE FIRST HAND -- I
ACTUALLY HAD A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS LAST YEAR AS YOU
MENTIONED -- WE SAW THAT HIGH
RISK OR HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS OF
KIND OF EXPANDED -- THROUGHOUT
THE SPEC OUT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE -- GOING MORE PLACES AND
WE KIND OF ARE NORMALLY AND
THINKING THAT FIRES WOULD GO.
SO AS A RESULT OF THAT I'M
WONDERING HOW WAS THE ONE
BILLION DOLLAR NUMBER DETERMINED.
AND HOW WILL YOU MANAGER MEASURE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE LOAN --
WELL.
IT'S IT'S HARD TO DETERMINE WHAT
THE ACTUAL NEED WILL BE AND MY
HOPE IS THAT -- THAT WOULD A
BILLION DOLLARS WILL BE ADEQUATE
IT'S A REVOLVING LOAN FUND SO IF
IT'S IF IT'S NOT ENOUGH WILL
KNOW FAIRLY QUICKLY IF IT'S TOO
MUCH WILL KNOW FAIRLY QUICKLY AS
WELL -- BUT IT SEEMS IT SEEMS
LIKE AN APPROPRIATE NUMBER
CONSIDERING.
THE KINDS A RETROFITS WE'RE
LOOKING AT HOW.
HAS THE RUNNING IT THOUGHT GIVEN
TO HOW TO MANAGEMENT MEASURE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE LOAN I MEAN
IS YOUR GOAL THAT A 100% OF THE
MONEY WILL BE USED.
OR THAT ARE YOU MEASURING IT
BASED ON WHERE HOMEOWNERS ARE
LOCATED I MEAN IS THERE ANY
THOUGHT GIVEN TO THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THAT -- I WOULD
I WOULD SAY THAT THE AND THE IF
HOPE HOPEFULLY THROUGH EDUCATION
THROUGH THE REGIONAL THE
REGIONAL -- GROUPS THAT WE'RE
CREATING HERE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT THE LOAN WILL BE
WILL BE FULLY SUBSCRIBED -- THAT
WOULD THAT WOULD BE THE GOAL AND
SINCE IT'S A REVOLVING LOAN FUND
OF PEOPLE WE PAYING BACK.
THEN THIS WILL CONTINUE TO HELP
FOR THE FUTURE LAND OWNERS AS WE
GO ALONG WE'RE FOCUSING ON THE
THE MOST SEVERE AREAS IN THE
STATE -- YOU KNOW IDEALLY
WOULDN'T WE WANT TO HAVE ALL
HOMES YOU KNOW HAVE THESE KINDS
OF HAVE THESE KINDS OF
PROTECTIONS AS WELL -- BUT I
THINK WILL YOU KNOW A LOT IS
GOING TO BE EDUCATION CHANGES IN
BEHAVIOR WHICH WE TYPICALLY FIND
TO BE HARD THINGS TO ACCOMPLISH --
BUT THEY'RE NECESSARY -- KNOW
THESE KINDS OF THINGS YOU KNOW A
DOLLAR YOU SPEND ON PREVENTION
SAVES YOU FOUR DOLLARS ON THE
OTHER END.
THROUGHHAVING TO FIGHT A FIRE
OR DO THE CLEANUP AFTERWARDS SO
IT'S IT'S REALLY IS MONEY WELL
SPENT.
THANK YOU AND THEN MY LAST
QUESTION -- DID YOU WANT TO ADD
TO THAT -- FIRST OFF I WANTED TO
TAKE A ON A MOMENT. TO TO DO A
FRIENDLY CORRECTION TO THE
ASSEMBLYMAN IT IS ONE DOLLAR FOR
SIX OO THAT IS THE STANDARD.
IN TERMS OF PROVEN COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS FOR BUILDING
MEDICATIONS IN THE WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE SO THOSE NUMBERS
HAVE BEEN PROVEN OUT THROUGH
LARGE FIRES IN OTHER COMMUNITIES
AND STUDIED FORENSICALLY POST
EFFECT.
RELATIVE TO THE EFFECTIVENESS
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
METRIC THAT -- SO IN THE LARGER
COMMUNITY -- IN THE FIRE OF BOTH
RESPONSE PREVENTION MITIGATION
COMMUNITY THERE IS PRESS PROCESS
AND PROGRAMS UNDER WAY WHERE WE
ARE CAPTURING THE ELEMENTS ABOUT
BUILDINGS.
AND WHAT KIND OF BUILDING
MATERIALS THEY HAVE WHAT KIND OF
FIRES ARE OCCURRING THE POST
DAMAGE ASSESSMENT PROCESS THAT
CAL FIRE USES TO EXAMINE
BUILDING STRUCTURES.
AND THE RESEARCH WORLD OUR
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS ARE
CURRENTLY DEVELOPING WAYS TO
ANALYZE EFFECTIVENESS RELATIVE
TO THESE INVESTMENTS SO THERE IS
A GROWING BODY OF OF WORK. TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY.
THANK YOU AND THEN MY LAST
QUESTION JUST FOR THE ADVISORY
BOARDS AYE I HEARD THAT THE
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN -- TO MOVE
THEM FROM BEING THESE AGENCIES
OR DISTRICTS TO BEING ADVISORY
BOARDS THE EIGHTEEN IS IT
AUTHORIZING THEM OR ALLOWING
ORDERS ARE REQUIRING THE BOARDS
OR I JUST.
WONDER WHAT THE VERB AS WERE FOR
ME [inaudible]
YEAH. TO SAY THAT THAT THAT IS
AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT -- WE
LISTEN LIVE IN EIGHT
GEOGRAPHICALLY LARGE AND DIVERSE
STATE -- ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH DOES NOT WORK WELL --
WHAT MIGHT BE IMPORTANT MISTER
BIGELOW'S COMMUNITY MIGHT NOT
MIGHT NOT HAVE MUCH MAYOR IN
YOUR COMMUNITY OR MISS RUBIO'S
COMMUNITY SO?
SO IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE --
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE HAVE THE
RIGHT PEOPLE ON THE GROUND TO
HELP PEOPLE FOR THE PARTICULAR
NEEDS OF THEIR OF THEIR
DISTRICTS AND SO THAT'S WHY THE
NUMBER.
IT'S A LARGE NUMBER BUT IT IS I
BELIEVE IT IS -- IT'S NECESSARY
TO REFLECT THE THE THE DIVERSITY
OF OUR STATE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
DOCTOR WAS A THE UNITED HELLO WE
ARE TRYING TO DO HERE -- AND AND
I UNDERSTAND THE DEVASTATION
THAT'S HAPPENED A COMMUNITY OF I
HAD.
FIRE READ THROUGH MY COMMUNITY A
COUPLE YEARS AGO AND YEAH I TRY
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THE
DEVASTATION TRYING TO DO THE
HARDENING OF THE HOMES AND STUFF.
MY MY REAL CONCERN ON YOUR BILL
IS ON PAGE SIX WINE THE TEEN --
THE STATE WILD FIRE PREPAREDNESS
BOARD IS HEREBY ESTABLISHED IN
STATE GOVERNMENT CONSISTING OF
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS.
ONLINE YOU STRIKE OUT EPARTMENT
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES THAN GOING
TO THE SECRETARY OF NATURAL
RESOURCES DIRECTOR OF FORESTRY
AND FIRE PROTECTION.
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION --
STRUCTURE OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES -- STATE FIRE
MARSHAL OF DIRECTOR OF OFFICE
AND PLANNING RESEARCH.
SECTOR DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS --
AND A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WITH
EXPERTISE IN FIRE SCIENCE
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR.
ON AND THEN THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO CONVENE THEY'RE GONNA SET UP
OTHER -- LOOKS LINE A EIGHTEEN
DIFFERENT DISTRICTS WITHIN THE
STATE. TO WORK ON A PUBLIC
CAMPAIGN TO TALK ABOUT FIRE
SAFETY EXETER CENTER MY MY MY
BIG QUESTION IS WHAT'S STOPPING
THEM FROM DOING THIS NOW -- AND
WHY AREN'T WE USING CAL FIRE TO
DO GRANTS FOR HARDENING.
HOMES I MEAN WHY WHY.
WHY WOULD WE INITIATE ONE MORE
GOVERNMENT FOR ONE MORE LAYER OF
RED TAPE?
AND WHEN WE WE'VE ALREADY GOT
ENOUGH OF TO JUMP THROUGH ENOUGH
OBSTACLES WHEN IT GOES TO
GETTING THINGS DONE AND GETTING
THINGS MOVING -- TO GET OUR
COMMUNITIES PROTECTED FOR FIRE
IN IN TO ME IT'S JUST ADDING
THAT ONE EXTRA LAYER.
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO
THROUGH AND WE NEED THE
SECRETARY SHOULD ARE TO BE
TALKING TO EACH OTHER.
I AM IN I I DON'T ASSEMBLY WE
NEED LEGISLATION FOR A SECRETARY
TO PICK UP THE PHONE AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION AND SAY HEY LET'S
GET THIS DONE WE HAVE AN ISSUE.
AND WE'RE ALREADY.
IN A STATE OF EMERGENCY -- THE
GOVERNOR'S DECLARED TO GET IN
THERE AND GET THINGS DONE NOW.
SO WHY NOT GIVE CAL FIRE THE
ABILITY DO GRANTS AND PULL THE
FUNDING AT A G. G. R. ATHE -- TO
DO HOME HARD.
WELCOME BACK TO YOU.
YOUR ORIGINAL COMMENTS WITH THE
DIRECTOR EMERGENCY SERVICES BACK
IN THE BILL SO THAT WE'RE
PUTTING THAT BACK.
ALSO PUTTING TO LEGISLATIVE --
APPOINTEES -- IT INTO BACK IN
INTO THE MIX.
I THINK THE CHALLENGES THAT.
WHEN IT COMES YOU KNOW -- OUR
OUR FOLKS A CAL FIRE ARE AMAZING
AT THE WORK THEY DO AND I HAVE
TREMENDOUS RESPECT FOR THEM AND
PUTTING OUT FIRES AND SO FORTH --
I THINK THE REALITY IS WE HAVE
ENOUGH MANPOWER -- TO DO IT GOT
TO DO THESE KINDS OF ACTIVITIES.
TO ACTUALLY DO THE FIRE
PREVENTION.
I WILL TELL YOU -- IN MY IN MY
DISTRICT RIGHT NOW -- WE STARTED
THE PROJECT WE PUT STARTED IN
OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR -- MEETING
WITH CAL FIRE THE CITY IN THE
COUNTY TO DO A MAJOR PROJECT TO
PROTECT THE CITY OF YOU CRIER --
IT'S TAKEN A WHILE TO GET THAT
OFF THE GROUND -- BUT IT'S A
KIND OF UNPRECEDENTED TO HAVE
THIS THE STATE THE CITY AND
COUNTY ALL WORKING TOGETHER TO
PROTECT TO DO A PROTECTION
PROJECT.
BUT IT IS NOT EASY TO DO AND ONE
OF OUR BIGGEST FEARS QUITE
FRANKLY HAS BEEN.
IS A WE HAD EARLY FIRE SEASON
WHERE THE FOLKS THAT ARE FROM
CAL FIRE GOING TO BE.
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE HELPING
US THROUGH THESE PROJECTS
THEY'RE GOING TO BE [inaudible]
GONE -- THEY'RE GONNA BE OUT
FIGHTING FIRES AND THAT'S JUST
PART OF IT PART OF THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE FACE THERE -- WE WE RUN
INTO THESE KINDS OF THINGS YOUR
EIGHT YEAR ANYHOW I I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S WHY
AROUND A BILL TO TAKE YEAH G. G.
R. F. FUNDS AWAY FROM MY FIGURE
ON GOING TO CAL FIRE FOR FOR
THESE VERY REASONS -- BOY
[inaudible]
IT'S IT'S MORE THAN THAT BECAUSE
NOW WE'RE GOING TO CREATE ONE
MORE AGENCY.
THE THAT'S GOING TO GET IN THE
WAY OF THIS I DISAGREE I THINK
THAT'S AGENCIES GONNA HELP TO
COORDINATE DOT -- EACH
COMMUNITIES IT EAT THESE THESE
EIGHT D. EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT
COUNCILS ARE GOING TO HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT
FOR THEIR INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITY.
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
STATE AGENCY THAT HAS THE RESORT
HAS RESOURCES EXPERTISE TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
SUPPORT. TO HELP THIS HAPPEN I
DON'T I DON'T SEE THIS IS AN
IMPEDIMENT I SEE THIS IS AS A
WAY TO GET THE JOB DONE BECAUSE
CLEARLY WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW.
ISN'T WORKING SO INSTEAD OF SAY
CAL FIRE CREE IN A POSITION
WHERE THEY HAVE A A PUBLIC
SERVICE.
OFFICER THAT'S GONNA HELP
COORDINATOR HIRE A COUPLE MORE
CREATING OTHER AGENCY WITH
OVERHEAD AND EVERYTHING ELSE IS
GOING TO ABSORB MORE FUNDING.
IS GOING TO HELP I JUST I I I
DON'T ANY JUST UP FIRE I I THINK
I THINK WE WANT TO GET TO THE
SAME GOAL WILL RUN DIFFERENT PAY
I'LL THINK CAL FIRE AND TWO MORE
PEOPLE IS GOING TO HELP US IN
THIS SITUATION -- THANK YOU --
MISTER GETTING IT I RESPECT YOUR
PAIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AS CHAIR
[inaudible]
LET ME.
JUST COMMEND YOU FOR ONE
STANDING UP YOUR COMMUNITY -- I
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE TOILED --
BACK AND FORTH -- I REMEMBER WE
WERE OUT IN THE COUNTRY AT A FLY
RIGHT BACK.
AND PUT YOUR PROFESSIONAL HAT TO
IDENTIFY YOU DO FORENSIC ON
THOSE WHO OF PASSION THE FIRE
AND CERTAIN THIS IS A WAY FOR
YOU TO STAND UP FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR COMMUNITY -- CERTAINLY MY
COMMUNITY IS DIFFERENT YOUR
COMMUNITY -- YOUR COMMUNITIES
MORE PRONE TO FIRES IN THIS
MATTER THAN MY COMMUNITY -- AND
PEOPLE OF YOUR COMMITTEE SHOULD
BE VERY PROUD THAT YOU'RE
STANDING OF DOING WHAT YOU
SUPPOSED TO DO AS A MEMBER OF
THIS BODY.
AND THAT IS PUTTING FORTH
LEGISLATION WELL THOUGHT OUT
LEGISLATION SO WE CONSIDERED I
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION BUT YOU KNOW. TO
HAVE ONE CREATE THIS IS A LONG.
IF WE PUT THE MONEY UP.
AS THE STATE.
THAT IS PAID BACK.
BY THOSE INDIVIDUALS AM I
CORRECT CORRECT SO.
IN TERMS OF WE MAY HAVE TO MAKE
SOME ADJUSTMENTS BECAUSE WE ARE
IN UNUSUAL.
CIRCUMSTANCES BECAUSE WE'VE
NEVER SEEN ANYTHING THIS KIND OF
DEVASTATION IN CALIFORNIA BEFORE --
SO WE HAVE NOTHING TO RECALL
BECAUSE THIS WE'RE IN -- WE'RE
STARTING BEGINNING AND WE ARE
LEARNING AS WE GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS AND CERTAINLY I THINK WE
CAN LEARN A LOT BY -- ONE
UTILIZING THIS REVOLVING -- FIND --
FOR PEOPLE TO DRAW DOWN BUT
AGAIN IT'S A LOAN.
THEY'RE GOING TO PAY BACK THIS
LONG AND IF YOU EVER BEEN IN A
SITUATION WHERE YOUR INVESTMENTS
SUCH AS YOUR HOME.
IS BEING DESTROYED BY A WILDFIRE
THEN YOU TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO REBUILD YOUR ENTIRE LIFE
NOT A WAFFLE BUT TRYING TO
REBUILD -- YOUR LIFE AND
CERTAINLY TO KNOW THAT THE STATE
IS STANDING BEHIND BY ALLOWING
ALONE -- TO TAKE PLACE I THINK
IT GIVES THOSE INDIVIDUALS SOME
KIND OF COMFORT AND I THINK THAT
YOU AGAIN WITH THE RETROFITTING
THINGS OF THAT NATURE WAS
ALREADY DISCUSSED HAVE ALREADY
BEEN DISCUSSED I DON'T WANT.
TO BELABOR THE TIME BUT I THINK
THIS IS -- IN THE RIGHT WAY TO
GO AND ALSO WITH THE COMMITTEE --
THAT YOU WANT TO START I WOULD
ASSUME THOSE INDIVIDUALS WILL BE
LOCAL INDIVIDUALS -- WHO HAVE
FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERTISE TO BE ABLE TO GUIDE
THE CONVERSATION TO WHERE IT
NEEDS TO GO AS RELATES TO THIS
ANY OTHER ISSUES COMING UP
CORRECT YOU'RE RIGHT ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT?
SO AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IT'S Y. ME THE MOST [inaudible]
MR COOLEY.
MISTER WHAT I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
JUST WANT TO OFFER SOME.
COMMENTS I MEAN I CAN SEE.
HOW IF WE HAD A CLEAR SENSE OF
DIRECTION?
YOU WOULD NEED TO PUT THESE
PEOPLE TOGETHER YOU JUST SORT OF
DO IT.
BUT MY GENERAL SENSE IS WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE WILDFIRE ISSUE.
IN A IN A IN A DIFFERENT WAY IS
NOT REALLY A FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
PROBLEM.
I THINK YOU DEAL WITH A WILDLAND
INTERFACE IT'S MORE OF AN AREA
OF MOUNTAINOUS TERRAIN HEAVY
TIMBER.
THESE ARE THE SORTS OF THINGS
MAYBE CHAPARRAL.
INTENTION APPAREIL AREAS THIS IS
NOT THE PREPONDERANCE OF WHERE
CALIFORNIANS LIVE [inaudible]
AND WHATEVER IS HAPPENING
CLIMATE WISE I ACTUALLY FAVOR
SOMETHING BOLD ON THE PART OF
CALIFORNIA.
SOMETHING LIKE A MARSHALL PLAN.
SO DO WHERE IS WE IS AN ENTIRE
STATE.
IT KNOWLEDGE WE HAVE
CALIFORNIA'S AT RISK. FOR
REASONS WE DON'T UNDERSTAND ALL
THE DYNAMICS.
AND WE START TRYING TO TACKLE
THE PIECES OF WHICH WE CAN.
I WANT TO SAY THIS IDEA OF
TRYING TO IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
HARDING SORTS OF THINGS THIS IS
NOT A UNIQUE CONVERSATION.
IF YOU'RE IN FLORIDA IF YOU'RE
ON THE IF YOU'RE ON THE GULF
COAST.
THE WHOLE ISSUE OF WHAT ARE THE
PROJECT IMPROVES A CREMATED
HUMAN HOMES HUMAN HABITATION. TO
MAKE IT MORE RESILIENT IN THE
FACE OF KNOWN THREAT.
THIS IS SORT OF A STANDARD TOOL
IN A TOOL KIT.
THE THINK ABOUT HOW YOU DEAL
WITH THESE SORTS OF THINGS.
ARM.
HONESTLY I WHEN I LOOK AT THIS.
OUR I VIEW THIS IS REALLY A
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW DO FOR
ALMOST FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS.
TACKLE A PROBLEM THAT IS.
INCREASINGLY PARAMOUNT FOR A LOT
OF OUR RURAL NEIGHBORS.
HOW DO WE AS A STATE PULL
TOGETHER?
AND IF IT DOES BECOME A RESOURCE
QUESTION.
BUT THERE IS NO DIFFERENT TO
WHEN KEN MADDY.
DID A HANDSHAKE DEAL AFTER LOMA
PRIETA EARTHQUAKE.
SO LET'S LET'S RAISE SALES TAXES
SO WE CAN REBUILD THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE RE REBUILT IN THE BAY
AREA.
YOU KNOW THAT'S MORE THE MODEL
OF HOW GOVERNMENT'S WORKS.
WERE THEN WITHIN THE AREA OF
CALIFORNIA WE TRY TO TACKLE ARE
PRESSING ISSUES -- SO WHY.
I LOOK AT THIS I THINK WELL
THERE'S A LOT OF OPEN ISSUES
HERE FOR B. AS A LAWYER WHEN I
READ THIS.
HOWARD ENTER TWINED TO THE CIVIL
CORD THE TRANSFER DISCLOSURE
STATEMENT IT'S INTEGRATED AND
EVERY WILL PROPERTY TRANSACTION.
HOW DOES THIS DO WILD FIRE
HAZARD JOAN INTEGRATE WITH LIKE
THE ALL CHRIS PRIAL SEISMIC
DISTRICTS SEISMIC MAPPING ISSUES
WHAT'S THE NATURE THE
CERTIFICATION THAT WE'RE DOING
HERE?
BUT I VIEW THIS IS THESE ARE
SORT OF NEEDS THE PEOPLE CAN
SORT OF FIGURE OUT HOW WOULD
FIFTY SCENES TOGETHER.
SURELY THERE'S A NEED FOR A
FUNDING STREAM BUT ACTUALLY
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
THOSE OF US WHO ARE ELECTED IN
TWENTY TWELVE OR NOW THE LONGEST
SERVING LAWMAKERS IN THE HISTORY
CONFERENCE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
AND THOSE WITH THE WAR LIKE IN
TWENTY TWELVE RUN THAT SAME PATH
YOURSELF.
WE NEED TO BE WORKING ON HOW WE
REINVENT THIS INSTITUTION TO
PULL TOGETHER FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE.
AND AND TAKE A MORE LONG TERM
VIEW OF ISSUES.
AND THAT'S SORT OF SO I SORT OF
THINK A BILL LIKE THIS IS
CHALLENGING AS IT IS.
IT'S SORT OF AN INVITATION TO
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE GROW THE
INSTITUTION. TO TAKE THIS MORE
WIDE RANGING VIEW OF THE WHOLE
STATE BEING AND THINGS TOGETHER.
AND I ACTUALLY SAVE FOR THOSE OF
YOU THAT HAVE SOME DISCOMFORT
WAS SORT OF THE CHARACTER
POLITICAL DIALOGUE IN OUR
COUNTRY. TO BE ABLE TO WRAP
AROUNDS RUN AN ISSUE THE
AFFECTION TIRE STATE AND LOOK AT
HOW THE WHOLE STATE WOULD PULL
TOGETHER.
IS ACTUALLY TAKEN OUR
GOVERNMENTS ARE INSTITUTION A
VERY HEALTHY DIRECTION.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT JUST
BECAUSE YOU'RE.
YOU KNOW MY COLLEAGUES FROM.
AN AIR THIS HAD RURAL
DEVASTATION.
I THINK IT'S AN ISSUE THAT I
ACTUALLY INTEND TO SUPPORT TODAY
AND I WOULD.
URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO THINK
ABOUT.
BUT NOT EVERYONE HAS TO BE ON
BOARD AT THIS TIME I MEAN I
THINK.
IT'S A TIME TO BE THINKING OUT
LOUD.
MOVING FORWARD.
SO -- THE THE WHOLE ISSUE OF HOW
YOU WOULD FINANCE A SORT OF
THING BUT I SORT OF THINK.
LIKE TO LOWER PUT EXAMPLE IF
YOU'RE TARGETING A COMPARATIVE
SMALL NUMBER OF FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WITH A FIX.
WILL SAY PUBLIC DOLLARS A LONG
RUN.
AND WE CAN FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
START COMMITTED REVENUE STREAM
TO THAT SORT OF MARSHALL PLAN
IDEA -- ITS ADVANTAGES THE STATE
AS A WHOLE [inaudible]
ARM SO.
I I ACTUALLY THINK THIS IS A YOU
KNOW I LOOK AT THIS BILL -- AND
I SEE THIS OFF WHEN I DRAFT
LEGISLATION MYSELF.
I PUT SOME IDEAS OUT THERE AND
PEOPLE TAKE POT SHOTS AT AND I
ALWAYS SAY.
I LIKE TO I AM DOING WRONG BY
THE WAY YOU'RE DOING IT NOT AT
ALL.
AND I LOOK AT THIS BILL MISTER
WOULD AND I THINK I LIKED WE'RE
DOING WRONG BY THE WAY I'M TO
LEARN NOT AT ALL A KIND OF MOVES
US ON A MORE COLLABORATIVE
PROBLEM SOLVING BASIS IN THE
WHOLE STATE.
IT STARTS TO TARGET AREAS WHERE
WE KNOW WE HAVE ISSUES AND
FRANKLY FOR ME AS A DEMOCRAT IT
SETS ME UP. TO REALLY RECKON
WITH ISSUES OF BY.
MORE RURAL CALIFORNIANS AND
REMIND THEM THAT.
THEY MAY FEEL THEY'RE FROM THE
GREAT STATE OF JEFFERSON.
BUT THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS THEIR BACK.
SO I THINK THAT'S THE RIGHT SORT
OF CONVERSATION TO HAVE IN OUR
DAY THANK YOU.
I JUST SAY A MILLION. FOR A
LITTLE LEVITY.
BUT NOT TO LIGHTEN THE POINT.
OKAY IS THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS
THAT HAVE A QUESTION -- DID
ANYBODY DOWN HERE TODAY MISS
ANYONE WANT TO BE.
I OKAY SO LET ME JUST KIND OF
STRUCTURE THIS FOR EVERYONE TO
GET US ALL BACK ON THE PAGE WE
DO HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
GIBSON SECOND BY MISTER SALAS.
A TO FOR IT TO PASS AND IT'S A
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE THE
ITEM AS AMENDED LET ME WITH
REFLECTANCE MAKE SURE WE'RE
CLEAR WITH THE AUTHOR.
AS WE UNDERSTAND IT YOU'RE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE --
AMENDMENTS OF REMOVING THE
PROVISIONS DESIGNATING THE
EIGHTEEN NEW REGIONAL WILDFIRE
PREVENTION DISTRICTS AS STATE
AGENCIES.
INSTEAD THEY WILL BE ADVISORY
BODIES TO THE NEW STATE -- BOARD
WITHOUT ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY
CORRECT AND THE OTHER ONE IS AT
THE DIRECTOR OF CAL -- YES ONE
OF POINT HE WITH CAL FIRE
PREVENTION EXPERIENCE.
FROM BOTH THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY TO THE NEW STATE BOARD
CORRECT OKAY AND THEN YOU ARE
NOT IN AGREEMENT WITH THE
COMMITTEE RECOMMENDED --
RETROFIT REQUIREMENT.
ARE YOU WILLING TO ACCEPT THAT I
BELIEVE THAT THAT.
THE THE WAY THE WAY WE
UNDERSTOOD THIS AND SO IF I IF I
AM WRONG HERE THAT MIGHT WINNER
STAND THAT WITH REGARD TO READ
FOR FITS -- WE'RE THROUGH THAT
WE WERE ASKING FOR YOU'RE ASKING
FOR CLARITY AROUND THOSE
RETROFITS IT WOULD -- WOULD BE
AT WHICH I AGREE WITH BUT NOT TO
REMOVE THE REST FOR FIT
REQUIREMENT IF YOU DO YOU DO
THAT YOU REMOVED THE HEART OF
THE BILL I SO I DON'T.
I THINK I MIGHT AS WELL JUST
PACK UP MY TEN GO HOME IF THAT'S
THE IF THAT WAS THE THE THE WILL
OF THE CHAIR SO.
OKAY SO GIVEN THAT SAID -- THIS
IT THERE IS A MOTION TO DO
PASSED -- AND THE CLARITY THIS
OR ANY CONFUSION ON ANYONE'S
PARKS THIS IS BEEN A LONG.
HEARING ON THIS PARTICULAR ITEM
DOCTOR WOULD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND STRAIGHT
FOR NURSE AND I THINK SPEAKING
FOR ALL OF US WE ALL UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS A MAJOR ISSUE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I AND I YOU KNOW
LOOK I AM VERY SENSITIVE TO THE
FACT THAT THE LAST THING I WANT
TO DO IS ENCUMBER PEOPLE WITH
ADDITIONAL COSTS I KNOW THAT
LIFE IS EXPENSIVE -- I THINK
LOSING YOUR HOUSE COULD BE THE
ONE THE MOST DEVASTATING THING
SHE COULD POSSIBLY EXPERIENCE.
LOSING A LOVED ONE IN A FIRE --
PASSED IT FOR AND DOES FAR
SURPASSED THAT -- WE ARE ALSO I
BELIEVE -- WE'RE SEEING THIS NOW.
ENTERING INTO AN INSURANCE
CRISIS IN IN MANY AREAS IN THE
STATE.
MANY PEOPLE HAVE SEEN THEIR FIRE
INSURANCE.
RATES.
TRACK A DRUG GO UP DRAMATICALLY
MANY PEOPLE HAVE FIRE INSURANCE
FOR DECADES ARE FINDING THEIR
FIRE INSURANCE -- CANCEL -- AND
I BELIEVE THAT THESE KINDS OF
ACTIVITIES TRYING TO GET PEOPLE
TO RETROFIT THEIR HOMES TO TRY
TO CREATE DEFENSIBLE SPACE IN
THE LONG RUN COULD POTENTIALLY
SAVE A LOT OF US A LOT OF MONEY.
AND KEEP US POTENTIALLY INSURED
OUT THERE AND SO I YOU KNOW IT
SUBSIDES I HOPE THAT PEOPLE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS NOT MEANT
TO BE PUNITIVE.
IN THE LONG RUN.
INEXPENSIVE RETROFITS DEFENSIBLE
SPACE THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
MIGHT ENSURE THAT YOU ARE FIRE
INSURANCE.
MIGHT ENSURE THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO
BUY A HOME -- AND AND ENSURE
THAT TRUTH WITH A MORTGAGE AND
SO -- HOPE IN THAT SPIRIT THAT
PEOPLE WOULD RECOGNIZE THAT --
THAT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND SO AGAIN
WANTING EVERYONE TO BE CLEAR
THIS IS A TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE NATURAL RESOURCES --
COMMITTEE AND I I COMMEND YOU
AND APPRECIATE IT.
AS I SPOKE EARLIER I COUNTY
INDICATED I WOULD BE A NO I
THINK AFTER HEARING ALL OF THIS
AND I WOULD RECOMMEND THIS TO BE
AT LEAST FOR THE REPUBLICANS IF
THEY WANT.
VOTE ANYWAY YOU WANT BUT I'M
GONNA NOT VOTE ON THIS BILL
TODAY -- SO YOU AND I CAN WORK
ON THAT ONE LAST LIEU.
AREA OF CONFUSION AND MAYBE EVEN
THE CHAIRMAN HIMSELF WOULD LIKE
TO CHIME IN ON A LITTLE BIT OF
THE CONFUSION ON THE RETROFIT
COMPONENT.
IF YEAH AND I'D BE WILLING TO
WORK WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF ON
RESOLVING THOSE ISSUES WITH THAT
SAID -- WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL I COULD WRITE BEFORE
COULD SURE FOR WITH YES ALL THAT
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE INDEED
TALKING ABOUT [inaudible]
YES.
OUR EVERY OKAY.
THIS IS A CLEAR.
EYES BUT BE SURE OKAY THAT
EVERYBODY ON THE DíAS UP THERE
IS CLEAR.
EVERYONE'S CLEAR THE THE STAFF
WILL HAVE A CLEAR.
THAT'S WHY SAID AND THE STAFF.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
IT MEANS THAT THAT AND I JUST
WANNA BE DIRECT [inaudible]
GREAT [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
NOT VOTING [inaudible]
YOUR CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO.
BROUGH NOT VOTING COOLEY HI
COOLEY I'D DAILY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
AND WE'RE GARCIA GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LOW.
LOW AYE MATHIS.
NOT VOTING ASEAN NATURAL
RESOURCES TALK MORE.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS [inaudible]
BLANCA RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION.
MISTER NAZARIAN YOUR WATER.
YOU HAVE.
EIGHTY FOUR TWO NINE WELCOME TO
THE DíAS.
MISTER CHAIR MOVE THE BILL.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON.
YOU HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
MATHIS THE SECOND BY MISTER
GIBSON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SUPPORT
YOU MIGHT HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO A MINOR PRESENTATION WHAT I'D
LIKE TO SAY IS THANK YOU FOR THE
SUPPORT SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL A I
ACTUALLY WANTED TO JUST --
COMPLIMENT MISTER COOLEY ON THE
COMMENTS HE MADE BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER IT'S THE
HIGHLY URBAN DENSE AREA OR THE
RURAL AREAS WE HAVE CHALLENGES
FACING ALL OVER CALIFORNIA SO.
SOME KIND OF A MITIGATING FUND
THAT ADDRESSES UP SEISMIC
ACTIVITY FIRES -- OR OR RUNOFF
IS ALL GOING TO BE IMPORTANT AND
IT'S GONNA BE A CONVERSATION
THAT I THINK IS EXTREMELY TIMELY.
PRESENTATION WOULD THANK YOU
HAVE YOUR WITNESSES TESTIFIED
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
DANIEL -- MUELLER ON BEHALF OF
THE EARTHQUAKE ENGINEERING
RESEARCH INSTITUTE AND SHANE
DILLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WOULD YOU
LIKE -- TO SURE DO YOUR
PRESENTATION GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND DANIELLE
MILLER WITH THE EARTHQUAKE
ENGINEERING RESEARCH INSTITUTE
WE ARE A TECHNICAL SOCIETY OF
EXPERTS DEDICATED TO REDUCING
EARTHQUAKE RISK BASED IN OAKLAND.
WE'RE HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TOOK FOUR TWO NINE WHICH
CALLS FOR A STATE WIDE INVENTORY
OF BUILDINGS KNOWN TO BE SUBJECT
TO DAMAGE OR COLLAPSE AND
EARTHQUAKES.
AND HELPS TO ESTABLISH A
MITIGATION PROGRAM FOR THESE
BUILDINGS THIS BILL REPRESENTS
AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP TOWARD
QUANTIFYING THE EXTENT AND
DISTRIBUTION OF THE PROBLEM
ACROSS THE STATE.
WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT THE FIRST STEP THAT THIS IS
A FIRST STEP TOWARD FUTURE
LEGISLATION THAT SUPPORTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN IDENTIFYING.
AND RETROFITTING THESE BUILDING
SOME OF WHICH ARE DOING THIS
ALREADY.
WE ARE PLEASE OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR
IMPLEMENTATION SITS WITH THE
SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION AND WE
HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THEIR
EXPERTISE TO DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENT THIS PROGRAM -- WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE SUCH AN
INVENTORY TO BE CONDUCTED AT THE
CITY LEVEL WHERE IMPLEMENTATION
WILL TAKE PLACE AND TO IDENTIFY
THE USE AND STRUCTURAL
DEFICIENCIES OF THESE BUILDINGS.
CALIFORNIA'S THE MOST
SEISMICALLY ACTIVE REGION IN THE
COUNTRY OUTSIDE OF ALASKA WITH A
99% CHANCE OF A MAGNITUDE SIX
POINT SEVEN OR GREATER
EARTHQUAKE BEFORE.
TWENTY FORTY TWO WE HAVE 66% OF
THE NATIONAL -- ANNUALIZED
EARTHQUAKE LOSSES AMOUNTING TO
THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN THE WORLD'S
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE TAKE
SIGNIFICANT MEASURES TO PROTECT
OUR ECONOMY RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES.
AND WE THINK THAT THIS BILL IS
AN EFFORT POURTANT FIRST STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION.
WE THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THIS
AREA AND FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SOCIAL SCORE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE AND CHANGE
OVER THE FIRST VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
OFFICIALS ARE CALVO.
WE WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLYMAN
AS WELL FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
SEISMIC RESILIENCY AND WE
SUPPORT OUT.
FOR TWENTY NINE SPECIFICALLY IN --
THIS BILL BUT WE SUPPORT THE
FOCUS ON CONSTRUCTION -- THAT
WAS.
PRIOR TO NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
AND THE FOCUS OF THE INVENTORY
ON MULTI FAMILY AND PUBLIC
ACCESSIBLE BUILDINGS WE THINK
THAT'S REASONABLE AND ACCOMPLISH
ABLE.
AT THIS POINT WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE REQUIREMENT TO SECURE
FUNDING FOR THIS EFFORT AND THE
SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION'S
LEADERSHIP.
ON ON PERFORMING THE INVENTORIES
ON BEHALF OF OUR SIX HUNDRED
SITTING COUNTY MEMBER BUILDING
OFFICIALS -- WE WANT TO ASK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
IN THIS EFFORT.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WITH
COMMITTEE GERMANY SMITHING ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
SUPPORT.
SEEING THEIR ADDITIONAL --
TESTAMENT SPORT WE HAVE ANY
TESTIMONY OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAVID
BONTA WITH SUMMER FAXING
STRUCTURAL ENGINEER IN SAN
FRANCISCO I DID SUBMIT A LETTER
TO THE COMMITTEE.
AND A FOLLOW UP EMAIL ASKING --
FOR KNOWLEDGE MAN MISTER DAYTON
TELLS ME THE LETTER WAS NOT
RECEIVED SO IF IT'S OKAY WITH
THE COMMITTEES AND THINGS NO
OTHER.
TESTIMONY I MIGHT ASK FR AN
ADDITIONAL MINUTE OR TWO TO MAKE
MY POINTS [inaudible]
THAT'S FINE.
THANK YOU AGAIN MY NAME IS DAVID
BONTA WITH SOME A STRUCTURAL
ENGINEER PRACTICING IN
SACRAMENTO AND SAN FRANCISCO I
REALLY DO NOT WANT TO BE HERE
TODAY IT IS DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
BE IN A POSITION OPPOSITE.
AN ORGANIZATION LIKE HE ARRIVE
WHICH I'M A MEMBER.
I'M ALSO MEMBER THE STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WHO IS NOT YET TAKEN
A POSITION ON THIS BILL ALSO TO
BE IN OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NAZARIAN WHO'S A CHAMPION
FOR SEISMIC SAFETY I RESPECT HIS
INTENTIONS 1100%.
ON THIS BILL AND I SUPPORTERS OF
THE BILL.
THREE NINETY THREE ON THIS BILL
HOWEVER IS MISGUIDED I THINK YOU
WILL ACTUALLY DO MORE HARM.
THAN GOOD WITH REGARD TO SEISMIC
SAFETY IN THE STATE BECAUSE OF
THE NATURE OF THE DETAILS OF THE
BILL AND THE TIMING.
THERE IS MOMENTUM RIGHT NOW IN
THE STATE AT THE SEA LEVEL.
AS DANIEL MENTIONED AT THE CITY
LEVEL IS WERE ALL SEISMIC
MITIGATION IS CONCEIVED AND
PLANNED AND LEGISLATED AND
FUNDED AND IMPLEMENT.
THIS MOMENTUM RIGHT NOW IN THIS
BILL WILL STOP IT HE WILL
INTERFERE WITH WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE RIGHT NOW.
LAW TELLS ALL THOSE
JURISDICTIONS TO WAIT THREE
YEARS FOR DATA.
THERE'S NO REASON WHY THEY
SHOULD WAIT THREE YEARS.
WE WANT A BILL THAT COULD BE
ACTUALLY MORE SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS CAN AND
ARE WILLING TO BE DOING.
I'VE DESIGNED AND IMPLEMENTED
MULTI BUILDING INVENTORIES AND
SEISMIC MITIGATION PROGRAMS FOR
STATE AGENCIES FOR CITIES AND
FOR PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS FOR
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS.
AND AGAIN I'M SORRY I HAVE TO
TELL YOU THIS BUT IT IS OKAY FOR
YOU TO BE IN FAVOR OF SEISMIC
SAFETY INSTALL VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL IT IS OKAY TO BE FOR YOU TO
BE IN FAVOR OF GOOD LOCAL
INVENTORIES AND STILL VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL.
IN FACT I ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON THIS BILL SO THAT IT CAN
BE RETOLD BEFORE IT MOVES INTO
THE FULL ASSEMBLY THERE ARE
IMPORTANT CHANGES THAT CAN BE
MADE TO IMPROVE THE BILL. FOR
ONE AS DANIEL ALREADY MENTIONED.
THE BILL NEEDS TO HAVE SOME
ACCOUNTING FOR THE USE OF
BUILDINGS INCLUDING HOUSING THE
CURRENT BILL EXEMPTS THREE
QUARTERS OF ALL THE HOUSING IN
THE STATE.
WHY DO THAT?
THE BILL OUGHT TO HAVE SOME
ACCOUNTING FOR LOCAL.
CONTEXT TO REMOTE TO SUPPORT
RESILIENCE SPACE PLANNING WHICH
IS DONE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY Là TO
RECOGNIZE WHERE ALL THE
MITIGATION WORK IS BEING DONE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
RIGHT NOW THE BILL SAYS INSTEAD
LET'S HAVE THE STATE DO
SOMETHING THEY'LL COLLECT ALL
THE INFORMATION AND THREE YEARS
FROM NOW WHEN THEY'RE DONE THE
DUMP IT ON THE CITIES.
AND THEN THE CITY'S DON'T WANT.
THERE ARE GOING TO USE IT.
SAM JUST CALL US AND JUST
ALREADY HAVE THEIR OWN MOMENTUM
AND THEY'RE DOING IT THE SMALL
JURISDICTIONS DON'T WANT TO BE
TOLD ANYTHING ANYWAY.
WHAT WE WHAT THEY NEED IS SOME
SUPPORT FROM THE COMMISSION SOME
OF THE ADVICE GUIDANCE TEMPLATES
ON HOW DO A RESPONSE WHEN
VICTORIA ONE RIGHT NOW THE ONLY
MODELS THEY HAVE TO FOLLOW OR%
THE BIG CITIES?
AND THE VERY PROACTIVE ONCE YOUR
GOOD BRING YOUR COMMENTS TO A
CONCLUSION THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT.
AGAIN THE GOOD NEWS IS THE BILL
CAN BE SAVED.
OUR INITIAL COUNTER BUILDING USE
THE SO CAL PURSUE SPECIFIC
CONTEXT IT NEEDS TO RECOGNIZE
THAT ALL THE WORK IS BEING DONE
OF A LOCAL LEVEL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT I SEE
SOME ADDITIONAL -- TESTIMONY AND
SO IN OPPOSITION.
JUST JUST REAL QUICK I'M RANCOR
STING AYE PRACTICING STRUCTURE
AND HERE I AM WITH THE
STRUCTURES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA'S THEY MENTION IS
PART OF OUR GROUP.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY AS HE
SAID WE DON'T YET HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS -- BOTTOM LINE
FOR US AND I WAS KEEP A QUICK WE
KNOW WE NEED TO QUANTIFY THE
PROBLEM RIGHT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT QUANTIFY THE PROBLEM
BUT WE ALSO.
NEED TO MAKE PROGRESS AND THAT'S
WHAT YOU CAN HER DAVID SAYING
RIGHT WE'RE TRYING TO DO BOTH
HERE AND WE WISH WE COULD DO
BOTH IN THIS BILL.
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH COMMISSION BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS WE NEED TO MAKE PROGRESS
ON THIS ISSUE THIS IS A FIRST
STEP OF ANYTHING THERE NEEDS TO
BE MORE WORK COMING AFTER THIS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
SEEING NONE OF AND BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS FOR A CUT
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M
JUST WOULD BE INTERESTED IN YOUR
RESPONSE TO THE GENTLEMAN'S --
COMMENTS WHAT THAT HE BROUGHT UP
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
RATHER THAN IN YOUR CLOTHES.
SURE HAPPY TO ACTUALLY I WAS
GOING TO OFFER TO ANSWER A
QUESTION.
I DON'T THINK I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF MEETING WITH THEM SO
I'M HAPPY TO DO SO -- THIS IS
THIS ISN'T OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW
NOTHING NEW THAT I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THAT IN FACT A
DIFFERENT VERSION OF THIS BILL --
WAS HAD GONE TO THE GOVERNOR
LAST YEAR AND WAS BE TOWED
BECAUSE OF THE POTENTIAL COST --
TO THE STATE -- SAID THIS WAS A
REDO AND AN ATTEMPT TO LOOK AT
IT DIFFERENT AND NOT PLACE THE
BURDEN ON LOCAL JURISDICTIONS --
IN FACT THIS ALSO.
LESSEN THE NUMBER OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH THIS THAT.
HAVE TO RESPOND TO THIS.
BUT I WAS TRYING TO FOLLOW WHAT
THE GENTLEMAN WAS SAYING PART OF
THE CHALLENGE.
IS THAT BUT IF YOU DON'T IN SENT
SOME OF THAT STILL LARGER CITIES
HAVE ALREADY BEEN DOING THIS
SIZE AS A STATE WE'RE ALREADY
BUT BEHIND THE GAME.
WHEN YOU HAVE PLACES LIKE LOS
ANGELES DOING AN INVENTORY AND
FINDING OUT THAT THERE ARE
FIFTEEN THOUSAND STRUCTURES IN
LA CITY ALONE NOT COUNTY LA CITY
ALONE?
THAT ARE VULNERABLE -- THAT BEGS
THE QUESTION OF WELL WHAT ARE WE
DEALING WITH AT THE STATE LEVEL
BECAUSE WE'RE STARTING TO PUT
DIFFERENT PLACE.
PIECES INTO PLACE WE HAVE A
REVOLVING FUND WE HAVE WE'RE
WORKING ON A TAX CREDIT.
BILL WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL THESE
DIFFERENT MIDI GUITAR.
MITIGATION OPPORTUNITIES BUT WE
STILL DON'T EVEN HAVE THE
PROGNOSIS OF EXACTLY WHAT IT IS
WE'RE DEALING WITH SO FIRST WE
NEED TO FIND THE INVENTORY AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY MISTER JONES SORT.
THIS IS ERIN AND I'M SO GLAD YOU
BROUGHT THIS -- I HAVEN'T WORKED
ON THESE ISSUES.
SINCE -- NINETY FOUR DURING THE
NORTHRIDGE EARTHQUAKE WAS
MERGING PARRIS COORDINATOR FOR
THE CITY.
AND YOUR WIFE AND I WORKED ON A
LOT UNREINFORCED MASONRY
BUILDINGS IN IT WAS A PLEASURE
WORKING WITH THEIR CHOOSE A
SMARTER.
TO TO AND IT'S BEEN REALLY WAS
REALLY REALLY GOOD. TO WORK ON
THOSE ISSUES BE SWEET TO SEE LOS
ANGELES HAS A THOUSAND BUILDINGS
AND WE TOOK INVENTORY.
AND WE FOUND HOW MANY WERE NOT
UP TO SEISMIC -- STABILITY WE
WENT TO THE VOTERS GOT THE MONEY
AND WERE ABLE TO FIX THAT.
IF IT WASN'T FOR EARTHQUAKES WE
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PUSH
CITIZENS TO DO THAT OR EVEN TO
DO THE INVENTORY.
UNFORTUNATELY SINCE I'VE BEEN
TAKEN OFF.
BEING EMERGING BRITISH CORD IT
WE HAVEN'T HAD A MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE SINCE -- NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR BECAUSE OF ME -- BUT
THAT BUT THE REAL PROBLEM IS OF
OF WE GET A CALL CRISIS COMFORT.
WE GET REALLY REALLY -- AT EASE
SINCE WE HAVEN'T HAD A
EARTHQUAKE WHICH IS FAR ENOUGH
BACK OF OUR MINDS WE HAVE A
MAJOR SIX POINT OH SINCE SINCE
BEEN.
AND WE GET LAZY.
AND WE DON'T DO THE THINGS WE
NEED TO DO THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT DOING IN HIS BILL SO I
COMMEND YOU FOR FOR DOING IT
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO BE VIGILANT
NOW.
BECAUSE WHEN WITH WHEN THE BIG
ONE DOES HAPPEN.
IS ALL GOING TO BE A BUNCH OF A
WISH I COULDA SHOULDA DONE
SOMETHING IN THE PAST SO I
COMMEND YOU FOR RECORD KEEPING
THIS ALIVE AND MOVING IT.
FOR THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE.
WE HAVE THE MOTION THE SECOND
THIS IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE -- I I WILL JUST TAKE THE
COMPLIMENT TO MY WIFE AS THE
CLOTHES THANK YOU SO MUCH I WAS
VERY APPROPRIATELY DONE.
GOOD RECOVERY THANK YOU SIR TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
GREAT.
HI THREE NINE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AYE YEAR CURRY.
AND YOUR CREE I BERMAN
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO.
BRO I COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
COOPER.
UBER HI DALY [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER I GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW I MATHIS.
MATHIS I MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE FINE KAMLAGER-DOVE
HI ROBERT RIVAS [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS I BLANCA RUBIO
[inaudible]
SALAS.
THAT BILLS OUT.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM SIX OUR
AGENDA WILL ASK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA PLEASE -- APPROACH AND
QUICKLY -- PERCENT HER BILL.
THIS SHOULD BE EFFICIENT --
PROCESS.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WAS GARCIA.
SB SIX FORTY FIVE PERMITS A
PERSON WHO IS BETWEEN EIGHTEEN
AND TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD
THIRTEEN A WORK PERMIT. TO WORK
THE BACK OF THE HOUSE OF A HEART
CLUB I RESPECT LASSEN AYE VOTE.
OKAY TESTIMONY SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE A TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE.
SEC TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT HI GREAT AND BIGELOW
BIGELOW I AND YOUR CURRY.
I YEAR CURRY I BERMAN
[inaudible]
CONTACT.
BRO.
BRO I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIVE SEND [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER ON LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW I AM MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MELENDEZ.
LENDERS HI.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I A BLANCA RUBIO.
SALAS [inaudible]
THE PLACENTA.
OKAY MEMBERS AT THIS.
MISTER CARROLL MOTION MOVE ITEM.
FOR WE'VE GOT A MOTION TO MOVE
THE SECOND -- HAVE A SECOND
[inaudible]
DONNA.
I WOULD LIKE OUR FIRST
[inaudible]
YES.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY HI GRAY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AND YOUR CURRY.
YOUR CURRY I BERMAN [inaudible]
CONTACT.
BRO.
BRO I COOLEY.
TIME COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY.
GALLAGHER AYE GALLAGHER AYE
GARCIA.
GIPSON [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
ON SORT.
NINE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW I MATHIS.
THIS I'D MELENDEZ.
IN THIS AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I READ THIS.
REMUS I READ IT RUBIO
[inaudible]
SALAS.
OKAY THAT BILLS OUT.
THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE THE
RETURNED ITEM FOR ON THE GENDER
THIS IS AB TWO FORTY SEVEN DOLLY --
AND SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GREAT HI GREAT I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW EYEING A YEAR CURRY.
AND YOUR CURRY I BERMAN.
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BRO I COOLEY.
HI COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
ABSENT [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
I'M SORRY I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW I'M NOT THIS.
MATHIS I A MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I BLANCA RUBIO.
SALAS.
THE BILL HAS FOURTEEN VOTES IT'S
OUT.
OKAY MEMBERS AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE ARRIVED AT THE SPEED DATING
PORTION OF YOUR PROGRAM AND WE
HAVE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PRESENTING BILLS WE'RE GONNA
BEGIN WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
WHO HAS TWO ITEMS ITEM -- THREE
AND TEN ON THE AGENDA.
MR LOW PLEASE APPROACHING
PRESENT YOUR BILLS.
FAVORITE MISS RESEARCHER DID YOU --
FOR FOR ME GO IN ORDER.
OF FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH
IS AB ONE SEVENTY SEVEN ELECTION
DAY HOLIDAY.
YES PERFECT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
A MISTER USE -- THIS COMMITTEE
HAS SEEN THIS BILL MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS AND YET WE ARE HERE WE
ARE AGAIN -- THIS HELPS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE AS MUCH OF
ORDER PARTICIPATION AS POSSIBLE
AND INCREASING VOTER RIGHTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FIVE OH HAVE
WITNESSES TO SPEAK BRIEFLY IN
SUPPORT.
TESTAMENT SUPPORT.
THE THANK YOU HELLO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JANE
HOOD I'M A SOPHOMORE AT UC
BERKELEY.
DURING THE FALL TWENTY EIGHTEEN
MID TERM ELECTIONS I ORGANIZED
VOTER REGISTRATION AND GET OUT
THE VOTE EFFORTS ON CAMPUS
ENSURING THAT THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THEIR VOICE
HEARD IN THE LAST ELECTION.
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
MANY STUDENTS AND YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO WOULD BENEFIT AND NEED THE
PASSAGE OF AB.
ONE SEVEN SEVEN THROUGHOUT THE
FALL I WITNESSED THAT MANY THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE RECENT
IMPROVEMENTS THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
MADE TO OUR VOTING PROCESSES.
SAME DAY REGISTRATION DROP BOXES
FOR BALLOTS AND VOTE BY MAIL
HELPED SO MANY STUDENTS CAST
THEIR VOTE.
I ALSO NOTICED HOWEVER AND I'M
CONCERNED WITH THE LIMITATIONS
OF SUCH CHANGES.
MANY FRANTIC STUDENTS APPROACHED
ME ON ELECTION DAY.
CONFUSED AND UNSURE HOW THEY
WERE GOING TO ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO VOTE.
BETWEEN CLASS AND WORKED THERE
WAS LITTLE TIME FOR STUDENTS TO
TRAVEL TO A VOTING CENTER AND
COMPLETE SAME DAY REGISTRATION.
THERE WAS LITTLE TIME FOR THEM
TO COMMUTE NINETY MINUTES TO
THEIR DESIGNATED POLLING
LOCATION AFTER CLASS AND WORK.
OUR SYSTEM CAN BE DAUNTING
COMPLICATED AND TIME CONSUMING
ESPECIALLY FOR FIRST TIME VOTERS.
CLEARLY THERE ARE STILL MANY
BARRIERS THAT EXIST IN THE WAY
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO VOTE MAKING
ELECTION DAY A HOLIDAY WOULD
REMOVE ONE OF THEM.
TIME.
OUR DEMOCRACY PRESENTS PEOPLE
WITH DIFFICULT CHOICES HOW CAN
WE GO TO SCHOOL AND WORK AND
CHILD CARE AND THE GROCERY STORE
AND READ THE ENTIRE VOTER GUIDE
AND VOTE ALL IN ONE DAY.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT NO
CALIFORNIAN HAS TO STRUGGLE TO
FIND THE TIME TO VOTE.
I MAKING ELECTION DAY A HOLIDAY.
AT UC BERKELEY WE ARE CURRENTLY
ORGANIZING AROUND THIS EFFORT TO
DESIGNATED AS A NON
INSTRUCTIONAL DAY FOR STUDENTS.
TO SWITCH CLASSES FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR STUDENTS TO VOTE
AND LEARN ABOUT CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
AS A CAMPUS.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THESE
ELECTION DAY FESTIVALS ARE IN
FACT SOME OF THE MOST A TIME A
FISHING TO AND ECONOMICALLY
EFFICIENT METHODS TO INCREASE
VOTER TURNOUT.
I STRONGLY URGE THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO PASS AB ONE
SEVEN SEVEN AND TO CONTINUE TO
REMOVE THE BARRIERS TO OUR
DEMOCRACY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN HOW
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS AB ONE SEVEN SEVEN
ENSURES THAT CALIFORNIA'S WILL
HAVE.
THE TIME AND OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE
BY MAKING ELECTION DATE A STATE
HOLIDAY AB SEVEN SEVEN AB ONE
SEVEN SEVEN DEMONSTRATES
CALIFORNIA STRONG AND UNWAVERING
COMMITMENT TO DEMOCRACY BY
ENSURING.
THAT THE ELECTORAL PROCESS IS
MORE OPEN AND ACCESSIBLE.
FURTHERMORE DECLARING ELECTION
DAY HOLIDAY I A HOLIDAY WILL
GIVE MORE WEIGHT TO AN IMPORTANT
DAY AND HELP FOSTER A SENSE OF
CIVIC DUTY CIVIC SPIRIT AND
ENGAGEMENT.
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THE CFE
SUPPORTS AB ONE SEVEN SEVEN ONE
SHOP SUPPORT THE REQUESTED YOUR
RIVAL THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY TESTIMONY
OPPOSITION.
EXCUSE ME MY APOLOGIES -- I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT THAT STILL OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIRMAN GRAY --
AND THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD MY NAME IS DAN ALBERT I
AM ALSO STUDENT UC BERKELEY I
SERVED AS THE VOTE COALITION
DIRECTOR FOR THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
MID TERM ELECTIONS.
IN WHICH I ALSO HELPED -- MY
PEER JANE HOOD WITH REGISTERING
STUDENTS AT UC BERKELEY I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN BECAUSE IT GIVES THE
ELECTORATE THE NECESSARY TIME TO
EXERCISE THEIR CIVIC DUTY.
WHILE ALSO IMPARTING GREATER
SYMBOLISM ABOUT CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
IN CALIFORNIA.
OTHER MANY WAYS TO APPROACH THE
ISSUE OF LOW VOTER TURNOUT AND
THERE'S NO ONE SOLUTION THAT
WILL BE THE PANACEA.
BUT THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO
APPROACH VOTING ACCESSIBILITY
FROM A VARIETY OF ANGLES AND
IMPLEMENT MANY SOLUTIONS THAT
WILL WORK IN TANDEM TO MAKE IT
THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS MORE
ENGAGING AND ACCESSIBLE. TO ALL
OF THE ELECTORATE THANK YOU.
AND HI MY NAME IS JEREMY I'M
ALSO SPEAKING IN SUPPORT UNDER
ME SIR I I'M I'M A COLLEAGUE OF
JANE DâN IS ALSO UC BERKELEY --
AGAIN STANDING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL MOSTLY BECAUSE OF THE
TIME CONSUMING NATURE.
SCHEDULES HAVE NOT JUST SOME
PEOPLE ESPECIALLY STUDENTS AND
HOW WE ARE ORGANIZING AROUND THE
VOTE -- IN THIS PAST MISTER
ELECTION WE FACE THAT ISSUE WITH
NUMEROUS STUDENTS I WAS GONNA
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE STUDIES.
THE TWENTY FOURTEEN PEW RESEARCH
CENTER REPORT SURVEYED
REGISTERED VOTERS WHO SAID IN
CLASS ABOUT THAT YEAR AND TWO
THIRDS SAID THEY DIDN'T VOTE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE TIME.
MORE THAN HALF OF THAT GROUP 35%
OF THE TOTAL SAID CONFLICTS WITH
WORK.
OR SCHOOL SCHEDULES GOT IN THE
WAY. TWENTY FOURTEEN TOUGH
SURVEY SHOWED SIMILAR RESULTS IN
THE MOST COMMONLY CITED REASON
AMONG YOUNG REGISTERED FOR NOT
VOTING WAS HAVING SCHEDULING
CONFLICTS.
WE BELIEVE MAKING ELECTION DAY A
HOLIDAY WILL REMOVE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER STUDENTS
FACE TOWARD BEING ABLE TO VOTE.
AND WILL MAKE IT MUCH EASIER FOR
THEM TO ACTUALLY DO SO.
THANKS.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
AND I WAS ALSO ASKED TO PASS
ALONG THE SUPPORT OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY --
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
GALLAGHER -- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- YOU KNOW AS AS AN A
LOT ALUMNUS OF UC BERKELEY --
REGISTERED IN BERKELEY.
CARRIED A FULL COURSE LOAD.
I WORKED AT THE RSF.
INVOLVED IN SEVERAL DIFFERENT
STUDENT ORGANIZATIONS VOTED
EVERY TIME.
MY PRECINCT WAS A BLOCK FROM
CAMPUS -- YOU KNOW WAS A VERY
DIFFICULT.
THAT TO VOTE SO I MEAN I KNOW.
MAYBE THINGS HAVE GOTTEN
CHALLENGING IN THE YOU KNOW
TWENTY YEARS SINCE I'VE BEEN.
ON THE BERKELEY CAMPUS BUT YOU
KNOW I I DON'T THINK IT'S THAT
MUCH OF AN IMPEDIMENT -- TO GO
TO VOTE BUT BUT ON THE SAME
LINES IF IT WAS A STATE HOLIDAY.
AS I AM UNDERSTAND THIS TO BE.
WOULDN'T THOSE CAMPUSES BE CLOSE
DOWN.
AND HOW WOULD THAT MAKE IT
EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE FOR
INSTANCE ON CAMPUS IF NO ONE'S
THERE AND IT'S A STATE HOLIDAY
THAT'S ONE OF ONE CONCERN.
THIS LOW YES SIR WAS THAT THEY
DID THE ONLY CONCERN OR ISSUE
THAT YOU HAD YEAH -- SURE.
I MIGHT HAVE A DRESS THAT IN THE
CLOSE AS I KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN
ACTION THE SAME SEE LAST YEAR IN
WHICH WE HAD ROBUST DISCUSSION
ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL.
OKAY WILL GO TO A SELDOM LENDERS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WON'T ASK ANY
QUESTIONS THEN SINCE -- WE'RE
NOT ADDRESSING THEM DIRECTLY
TODAY I WILL JUST SAY THAT -- I
HAVE. FIVE KIDS TO THEM IN
COLLEGE BOTH OF THEM MANAGE TO
BE ABLE TO VOTE ONE ACTUALLY
MANAGED TO VOTE -- FROM BOOT
CAMP.
WHILE HE WAS IN THE NAVY -- SO
CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE.
YOU CAN BE A PERMANENT ABSENTEE
HAVE THOUGH BY MAIL THERE ARE SO
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS TO VOTE IN
CALIFORNIA I'M NOT CERTAIN DATA --
AND NOT ON STATE HOLIDAYS IS
NECESSARY OR THAT IT WOULD HAVE
THAT MUCH OF AN EFFECT ON THE
VOTER TURNOUT BUT I AGREE WITH
YOU AND WITH.
YOU KNOW THE NOTION THAT WE WANT
MORE PEOPLE GETTING OUT THERE
AND VOTING I JUST I DON'T SEE
THAT THIS WOULD CHANGE THAT BUT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS.
THIS LOW WE'VE HAD THIS BILL
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE -- SEVERAL
TIMES CERTAINLY SOME.
I'VE HEARD SOME.
QUESTIONS CONCERNS LEVELED --
YOUR WAY THAT -- THE BARRIERS
PERHAPS ARE QUITE AS HIGH -- NO
ONE SEEMS TO SPOKE AND TO THE
MERITS OF HAVING A HOLIDAY
REGARDLESS OF THE BARRIERS --
HAVING SAID THAT THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE.
THAT AN EVENT AND DRIVING THAT
THE MORE WITH THE MORE DIFFUSE
WE MAKE OUR VOTING --
ACCESSIBILITY AND METHODS THAT
LOWER PARTICIPATION YOU SEE AND
THEN ACTUALLY.
CENTRALIZE FASHION -- AN EFFORT
THAT CAN INCREASE PARTICIPATION
AND ALL THE WAY UP TO THE
EXTREME SIDE OF THAT DEBATE --
LIKE YOU SEE IN AUSTRALIA WHERE
THEY HAVE MANDATORY.
VOTING -- ON I DON'T LIKE PAYING
TAXES AND YOU'RE GOING TO SHARE
MY SUPPORT -- HERE TODAY ISSUE
HAVE PREVIOUSLY THIS COMMITTEE --
WITH THAT I'LL.
LEAVE IT TO YOU FOR YOUR CLOTHES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR CO
AUTHORING.
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
MEMBERS AND THERE ARE CURRENTLY
EIGHTEEN OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
ELECTION DAY AS A HOLIDAY THIS
IS NOT SIMPLY TO GET A
PARTICULAR PARTISAN.
THE GROUPING -- TO INCREASE
THEIR VOTER TURNOUT IN FACT
INDIANA.
KENTUCKY LOUISIANA MONTANA NORTH
CAROLINA WEST VIRGINIA ALL HAVE
ELECTION DAY AS HOLIDAYS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE S. THE
IMPACT OF AN ELECTION DAY AS A
HOLIDAY TO INCREASE THAT OF A
VOTER PARTICIPATION BUT WHAT IS
ALSO THE IMPORTANCE OF OTHER
STATE HOLIDAYS LET'S SAY LIKE.
MARTIN LUTHER KING DAY OUR
PRESIDENTS DAY OR CESAR CHAVEZ
DAY WHICH THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSED AS A HOLIDAY IN TWO
THOUSAND YES WE WILL RECOGNIZE
AND PROVIDE A DECREASE
OPPORTUNITY.
FOR VOTER PARTICIPATION BUT
WE'RE ALSO DOES THIS DO IT
ALLOWS US TO PAUSE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THIS
DIALOGUE IN CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHY DO WE HAVE THIS DAY OFF.
AND WHAT DO WE CARE ABOUT WHAT
IS OUR OBLIGATION AS A SOCIETY
TO PARTICIPATE IN HOLD OUR
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES
ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT AND
THAT WE WILL FIND EDITION A WAYS
TO INCREASE PARTICIPATION AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE INCLUDING --
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TAKE THE
TIME OF THE DAYS LOOK ON THE MLK
DAY WE HAVE A DAY OF SERVICE
INDIVIDUALS GOING ON SAYING WHAT
IS THEM OKAY.
ALL ABOUT AND THEY DO
INDIVIDUALS DO DAY OF SERVICE --
AND SO VOTING CENTERS WILL
INDEED BE INCREASED AND THIS
TERMS OF THE CAPACITY OF WHICH
PEOPLE HAVE TIME TO DO SO -- AND
THIS IS A RECORD THAT THE STATE
IS GOING AN AUTOMATED VOTER
REGISTRATION PROPOSALS FOR LIKE
IN THE HIGH TECH SECTOR.
SO THIS IS CONTINUOUS OF THE
DIRECTION WE'RE HEADED IN AND I
RESPECT AS PRIVATE.
I JUST WANTED.
SO WHY ARE YOU MY ONE S. AS THAT
ON THE MICROPHONE.
YEAH I JUST WANTING CLEAR IF I
WOULD STATE CAMPUSES LIKE YOU
SEE YEARS CSU WOULD THOSE BE
CLOSED DOWN BECAUSE IT'S A STATE
HOLIDAY YES.
OKAY WE HAVE YOUR CLOTHES WE HAD
A MOTION THE SECOND.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY HI GREAT I BIGELOW.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
YOUR CREE AYE BERMAN.
BONTA [inaudible]
THROW [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER.
COOPER HI.
DALY [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER NOT [inaudible]
GALLAGHER NOW [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
GIVE SEND.
JONES SAWYER HI JOHN SOMEWHERE
HI.
LACKEY NOT ALL [inaudible]
LACKEY NOW [inaudible]
LOW.
I'VE LOW I MATHIS [inaudible]
WELL.
MATHIS NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I RUBIO.
SALAS.
THAT THE NEEDS FOR VOTES WILL
ALLOW LEAVES ARE ALL OPEN AND
REPORT BACK TO MR Là.
THANK YOU.
NOW THAT BEING YOUR FIRST
ATTEMPT AT THE SPEED DATING
PORTION THE PROGRAM WE'RE GONNA
GIVE YOU A SECOND CRACK ON ITEM.
TEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH RICHARD
THIS IS ANOTHER OF OUR REPEATER --
BUT I'M MOVING THE BILL WE WILL
CONTINUE THAT.
SUCCESS I HAVE LESS AND LESS IN
IT IN BROWN RECENT SUPPORT A
VERY BRIEF THANK YOU VERY VERY
BRIEF THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
PERSONAL SOME ELECTION ANHEUSER
BUSCH.
I THINK YOU TO THE CHAIRMAN THE
VICE CHAIRMAN THE STAFF THE
AUTHOR FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL LAST YEAR WE REALLY FORGED
A COMPROMISE WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS.
ALL LAST YEAR ON THIS MEASURE
WAS UNSUCCESSFUL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE DUE IN LARGE
PART TO IT A DEPARTMENT FINANCE
ANALYSIS WITH COST ASSOCIATION
WITH ENFORCEMENT.
WE ARE COMMITTED -- TO WORKING
ON THAT COSTING AND WITH AB
SCENE WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS IN
YOU ORDER BECAUSE NO YOU ORDER
CHAMPAGNE YOU HAVE AN
EXPECTATION WHAT THAT CLASS IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE WE WANT TO
BRING THAT EXPECTATION TO BE OUR
CONSUMERS.
AND CREATE THAT SAME EXPECTATION
FOR OUR BEER CONSUMERS IN
AMERICA SO APPRECIATE YOUR ABOUT.
MISTER CHAIR BRIAN RECENT ON THE
HAVE A MIDDLE COURSE ALSO
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS COMMITTEE
CHRIS WALKER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERS
ASSOCIATION WERE IN THE OTHER
CATEGORY TODAY -- WE ARE NEUTRAL --
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO OF LAST YEAR
OF THE DEAL THAT WE WORKED OUT --
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT THE
ENFORCEABILITY SO WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR WORKING WITH THE
SUPPORTERS -- IN ABC IN WAYS
THAT WE CAN MAKE THIS BILL
ENFORCEABLE SO IT'S NOT A
VIOLATION OF TITLE SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY.
MISTER CHAIR MATT BROWN WITH THE
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT.
EXCELLENT ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
CNN WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
MR MATHIS.
YEAH MY MY COLLEAGUE NEXT TO ME
SIEU AFRAID TO ASK THIS BUT WITH
A COMMON -- CAME UP WAS IS THEIR
CORN SYRUP IN IT SO I I DON'T.
MR COVERS WONDERING THAT'S THE
SUBJECT OF LITIGATION SIR WE
CAN'T COMMENT ON ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
SURE.
GREAT HI GRAY I BIGELOW.
AND YOUR COURAGE.
YOUR CURRY I BERMAN [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY.
GALLAGHER YOU MY LOVE.
YEAH [inaudible]
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON.
JONES SAWYER -- JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW I'D MATHIS.
MATHIS I MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ I KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
REVERSE.
REVERSE I RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
THE BILL IS OUT.
OKAY -- MISTER GALLAGHER YOU'RE
PUT ME IN COACH MOMENT HAS
ARRIVED ITEM NUMBER.
TWO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND FROM MISTER COOLEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS
IS A GREAT BILL AB FORTY ONE
THAT WOULD HELP WITH DEBRIS
REMOVAL AND COVERING.
THE THE LOCAL COST SHARE -- FROM
THE CAMPFIRE.
THAT WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION.
YEAH SO WHERE DOES THE RECALL
YODER WITH THE COUNTY BIãU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE MEMBERS
PAUL YOU'RE ON BEHALF OF THE
BUTTE COUNTY FORCING RESIDENTS
ONLY IT'S FOR THE BILL BUT I
REALLY WANT TO UP FROM THE BOARD
EXTEND A BIG THANK YOU TO ALL
THE MEMBERS WHO MADE IT UP -- TO
TOUR THE FIRE AREA AND THE BOARD
IS VERY APPRECIATIVE THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
CARE SINGLE PICKY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
JEFF NEAR WITH CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT.
STACEY HEATING RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
ROBERT SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
MATT BROWN WITH THE TEAMSTERS IN
SUPPORT.
AFFECT VERSUS EFFECT SUPPORT.
A DIGITAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
SEEING NONE A TESTIMONY
OPPOSITION.
SEE NOW WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY THANKS VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THE BILL FOR
IT I UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES ARE
GOING WITH AND I'D LIKE TO BE A
CO AUTHOR OF IT'S A FOOT.
OKAY.
ABSOLUTELY I THINK WE HAVE
MISTER COOLEY AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
BE ADDED AND OF COURSE WE'D.
LOVE TO DO THAT IF THAT'S PART
OF THIS PROCESS HERE TODAY
.
WELL CERTAINLY ENTERTAIN
I RUBIO
[inaudible]
SALAS.
THE BILL IS OUT.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING.
TO ASK MISTER JONES SAWYER.
TO ROACH AND PRESENT AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOUR RELATING TO
THE OFFICE MEMBERS SERVICES.
CALIFORNIA OLYMPIC AND
PARALYMPIC PUBLIC SAFETY COMMAND.
SECOND WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND RESURGENT SORE.
AB HELLO AB -- SEVENTEEN FIFTY
FOUR REQUIRED OFFICE OF
OF MERCY
SERVICE TO ESTABLISH A
CALIFORNIA OLYMPIC AND PARA.
OLYMPIC PUBLIC SAFETY COMMAND TO
FACILITATE PUBLIC SAFETY AND
SECURITY AT THE TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC
GAMES IN LOS ANGELES THIS MODEL
WILL ALL STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AND WILL ENSURE IF EFFECTIVE
COMMUNICATION COORDINATION AND
EXECUTION OF SECURITY PLANNING
AMONG KEY STAKE HOLDERS AT THE
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL IN
THE EARLY YEARS LEADING UP TO
THE GAMES.
THIS EARLY COORDINATION AND
PLANNING IT WILL UNDERPIN A
SEAMLESS TRANSITION TO THE
NATIONAL SPECIAL SECURITY EVENT
FRAMEWORK THAT WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED A FEW YEARS BEFORE
THE GAMES.
SO WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS IMPORTANT PLANNING
LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL -- TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OF THE TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF MISTER BRO.
THANKS CHAIR -- MISS JONES
SAWYER IS A GREAT BILL I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY WHEN I WAS A BUSH
APPOINTEE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS. TO BE THE LEAD
FOR THE AGENCY TO THE WHITE
HOUSE BECAUSE THE COMMAND CENTER
WAS AT THE VA MEDICAL CENTER IN
SALT LAKE CITY.
AND SO -- WE'RE RIGHT ACROSS THE
FOOTBALL STADIUM AND SO I'VE GOT
INTRICATE KNOWLEDGE OF THIS WENT
THROUGH IN TWO THOUSAND TWO SO
IF I COULD BE OF ANY ASSISTANCE
BUT A GOOD JOB OF GETTING IN
FRONT OF THIS.
WITH THE YEARS TO COME.
THANK YOU MISTER BRO.
OKAY ADICIONAL QUESTIONS COUNCIL
MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS DUE PASS. TO LEARN THE
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE.
NO NO.
NO -- WE'RE GOING TO CALL AN
AUDIBLE ON THE AND WE'RE GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND DO PASS THIS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
I ALMOST LITTLE BY.
SELECT A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
GRAY.
HI THREE I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I AGUIAR-CURRY.
AND YOUR CURRY BERMAN
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO.
BRO I COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY.
DAILY I GATHER AYE GALLAGHER AYE
GIPSON.
JONES SAWYER BY JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY I'VE.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS ARI MELINDA'S MELENDEZ I
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I REAVIS.
LEAVE US I RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
THE BILL HAS FIFTEEN VOTES IT'S
UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE GOING
TO MOVE TO ITEM ELEVEN ON YOUR
AGENDA -- MISTER BIGELOW AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE THIS IS
OUR FINAL ITEM.
MEMBERS SO -- ANY MEMBERS AS
FROM COMMITTEE PLEASE RETURN --
ADD ON ANY VOTE YOU'VE MISTER
WILL BE WRAPPING UP COMMITTEE
HERE SHORTLY MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
FROM MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO REPRESENT AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WHICH
WOULD MAKE IT EASIER FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO REMOVE DEAD AND
DYING TREES.
I HOPE THAT YOU ALL HAD A CHANCE
TO LOOK AT THIS BILL AND MAKE
YOURSELF FAMILIAR WITH IT.
AND ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
THE STATION IN SUPPORT.
STACEY HEAT RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
XRAY TESTIMONY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS.
WE HAVE A MOTION -- FOR MR DAILY
AND A SECOND FOR MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
GREAT.
HI GRAY AYE BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW
AYE AYE CARE CURRY.
YOUR CURRY I BERMAN.
A MAN I BONTA -- BRO I COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER I AT GARCIA GIPSON.
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE I
KAMLAGER-DOVE I AGREE THIS.
REAVIS HIGH RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS. SIX OR NOT IT'S OUT.
OKAY MEMBERS THAT BRINGS US TO
OUR CONCLUSION OF THE HEARING
TODAY WE'LL GO AHEAD AND LEAVE.
THE COMMITTEE OPEN. FOR FIVE
MINUTES SO THAT FOLKS CAN ADD ON
TO ANY BILLS THEY MAY HAVE
MISSED.
OKAY WALL LINE OPEN.
THE ROLE ON ITEM ONE A. B. --
THIRTY EIGHT WOULD [inaudible]
RIGHT.
HI GREAT I AGUILAR CURRY.
I BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY NOT VOTING.
LACKEY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
MELENDEZ NO [inaudible]
REVERSE [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS HI.
THAT BILLS OUT WILL MOVE TO ITEM
TWO MEMBERS -- SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THIS IS AB -- FORTY ONE
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW ON BIGELOW I BERMAN I
BONTA.
BONTA MY BRO [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
BRO I DALY.
DALY I GIPSON [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
I'M SORRY KAMLAGER-DOVE
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE I RUBIO
SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS.
NINE THE BILLS OUT [inaudible]
ITEM. THREE AB ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
LOW PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BIGELOW NO.
BIGELOW NOW.
BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BONTA AYE BRO [inaudible]
BRO NOW [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOLEY NOW [inaudible]
DALY.
I'M SORRY.
COOLEY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DALY I GIPSON [inaudible]
BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO EYEING SALAS
[inaudible]
SALAS AREN'T.
THE BILLS OUT.
WILL MOVE TO ITEM FOR AB TWO
FORTY SEVEN DOLLY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BERMAN.
BERMAN I RUN TESTS.
BONTA I DALY [inaudible]
DALY I SIERRA GIPSON
[inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS I AT THE BILL'S OUT.
MOVE TO ITEM. FIVE ON THE AGENDA
AB FOR TWIN AND HIS AREA PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
CONTACT I DALY [inaudible]
DALY AYE.
LACKEY I'M SORRY RUBIO.
RUBIO EYEING SALAS.
SALAS AYE.
THEY WERE GONNA MOVE TO ITEM.
SIX ON THE AGENDA AB SIX FOUR
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BONTA I DALY [inaudible]
REALLY I GIVE SEND [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS HI [inaudible]
GIPSON AYE.
OKAY -- MOVE TO ITEM SEVEN A. B..
ACTUALLY SCRATCH THAT WE WILL
MOVE TO ITEM -- TEN A. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY THREE LOW PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BIGELOW HI BIGELOW I BERMAN.
I BONTA.
BONTA I A BRO.
BRO I DALY.
DALY I GARCIA GIPSON
[inaudible]
GIPSON EYEING [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE.
THE BILL SO IT -- ITEM ELEVEN A.
B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CONTACT.
BONTA I GIPSON [inaudible]
GIPSON AYE [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO I SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS AYE.
THE BILLS OUT.
ITEM FOURTEEN ON THE AGENDA SB
SIXTEEN OR ONE RAMOS PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
YOUR CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN I A BONTA.
BONTA AYE BRO.
BRO I GALLAGHER.
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER AYE.
LACKEY [inaudible]
LACKEY I REAVIS.
REVERSE AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO AYE.
THE BILLS OUT.
GALLAGHER CALENDARS AYE.
ITEM FIFTEEN AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
I BONTA [inaudible]
BONTA EYEING.
GIVE SEND.
GIPSON EYEING.
BLOCK AT BLANCA RUBIO.
LIKE RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS.
THE BILLS OUT MEMBERS WILL
RETURN TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR --
SEARCHES PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
DALY I'M SORRY I'M SORRY BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BONTA I DALY.
DALY AYE.
GIPSON.
GIPSON NINE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE.
CONSENT CALPERS OUT WITH THAT
MEMBERS -- THE WE'LL LEAVE.
OPEN FOR TWO MINUTES FOR ANY
ADDITIONS AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO ADJOURN
.
WELL MISTER GIBSON IS A CO
AUTHOR JOHN SORRY BILL.
WITH THAT MEMBERS COMMITTEES
ADJOURNED